请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
好了 来大家安静一下 安静一下回到我们的课程当中来
接下来我们其实两周的基础课我们就算是告一段落了
其实大家会发现两周的基础课里头我们花了大量的时间让大家去干嘛呢
花了大量的时间让大家去做一件事情叫做和有的概念
所以大家可以看到在两周的基础课程结束以后
按理来讲到了整个运营阶段你们现在应该有哪些东西呢
一你们得要有电你们最起码店铺里头有电
二你们店铺里头最起码要有10款以上的商品
为什么这样去讲呢
原因是因为今天的话呢其实会进入到整个运营阶段
运营阶段去解决的是什么问题呢
大家可以去试一下按照你们在整个基础阶段里头
你们去做的所有的动作
比如说你们上传的产品
比如说你们发布的短视频
你们会发现虽然说大家都有了
但是你们面临最大的问题是什么
你们就算有产品
你们也卖不掉
你们没有流量
第二个你们虽然说啊
大家我看到大家很努力拍了很多的视频
但是在运营阶段我要给大家泼一盆冷水
你们拍的所有的视频
你们可以尝试着去投一下广告
投完广告以后你们会发现一个扎心的事实
什么事实呢
你们花这一百块钱你们会一单都不出
所以呢我们在整个运营阶段里头我们去解决大家什么样的问题呢
解决大家呢四个维度的问题
哪四个维度的问题呢
第一个维度
卖什么产品
因为真的生意能不能做起来
包括我们在座很多同学说
老师啊我很迷茫
其实生意核心的理念是什么呢
其实是行业和选品
所以呢我们在整个运营阶段里头呢
其实是会围绕着两个板块来讲
哪两个板块呢
其实在整个抖音的第一节课里头
我们就跟大家去讲了
抖音呢其实呢真正来未来来做的就做两个板块
一个板块呢
是通过商品卡带货
另外一个板块的话呢
是通过直播来带货
所以呢我们在整个运营的板块里头呢
我们先不说是商品卡还是直播
第一个板块当中呢
先去解决行业和选品的问题
第二件事情去解决什么问题呢
我想问的是大家产品发布起来以后
你们会发现最痛苦的是店铺里头没有流量啊
店铺里头没有人是这样的道理吧
所以呢我们在整个第二个板块呢
大家其实是可以看一下
可以看什么呢
你们在商品卡里头你们会发现
这里头有很多的流量渠道
里头有什么搜索啦
里头有什么猜你喜欢啦
包括我也知道我们在座的很多小伙伴呢
可能尝试着开播了
然后呢
你们会发现第二件事情的话
你看在整个直播的这个入口里头
它也也会有很多这种直播推荐啦
然后呢会有什么搜索啦
会有什么短视频
所以呢在整个第二个维度呢
我跟大家来聊一聊
我跟大家来讲一讲
这些入口平台怎么样
它才愿意给你们给流量
为什么大家现在去做的很多事情是无效的
为什么大家做了很多事情
它的流量没有进来
所以呢整个第二个板块当中呢
我们来研究一下整个流量入口
但是研究完流量入口以后
你们会发现好像懂了
但是好像又没有懂
所以呢第三件事情是干嘛呢
第三件事情的话呢
我们其实是要解决两个核心东西
一个核心的问题呢
是怎么把一条链接从无到有
把它给卖出去
把它给做起来
第二件事情的话呢
其实呢是围绕着整个直播间
怎么把直播间呢给它做起来
所以呢我们会去讲商品卡的玩法和策略
我们会跟大家呢
去讲整个直播间的玩法和策略
所以总的讲起来啊
运营课程里头去解决的是三件事
哪三件事呢
一卖什么货
第二件事情的话呢
怎么样才能够有人
第三件事情呢
怎么去能够有人之后
把我这条货给卖出去
怎么能够呢
把人给带进来
所以呢
基础课程当中解决的是从无到有的过程
那大家先有
那么运营课程里头解决的是什么呢
其实运营课程里头我们的节奏会非常的快
其实不太会给大家留大量的时间让你们去做什么
其实呢就是去解决一件事情
怎么去卖货
好
那么其实呢我们会在整个运营课程里头呢
我们会分成两个板块来讲
哪两个板块呢
第一个板块当中的话呢
我们差不多会花三天的时间
这三个整天的时间跟大家呢去讲讲商品卡
当然了我看到我们有很多新面孔啊
就很多商家呢
可能不理解什么是商品卡
什么是直播
花一个简短的时间跟大家呢来介绍一下
那么什么是商品卡呢
商品卡是什么呢
就是大家其实可以到你们的整个抖音里头去看
然后在抖音上面的这个位置
从大家看见没有上面是不是有一个抖音商城啊
什么是商品卡呢
商品卡呢 商品卡其实是客户通过抖音商城这个入口进去
他到这个入口里头
他不管他是通过搜索
他不管是通过这个页面里头
他是直接的去搜索
还是通过底下的这个位置里头
他点进去
然后呢买东西
因为这个界面里头进去以后
客户看到的是什么呢
就是大家会发现这个界面里头点进去以后
客户看到的是一个类似于这种卡片式的这样的一个东西
看见没有
是不是类似于卡片式的这样的一个界面啊
所以呢我们一般呢把这种界面就被称作为商品卡
其实说的更加直白一点
所谓的商品卡就是大家在抖音里头做了传统电商的生意
就是你们在抖音里头做了多多的生意
你们在抖音里头做了淘宝的生意
它的载体是什么呢
它的载体其实是一张一张的图片
一张一张的卡片式的这种成交
所以呢这个呢就叫商品卡
那么第二大载体是什么载体呢
大家呢会发现第二大载体呢就是我们的客户啊
在抖音这里头大家去搜
搜完以后呢
大家呢去搜索垃圾袋
然后搜索完垃圾袋以后
大家可以看到这个位置里头也有一些人
大家可以看见没有
它的在整个短视频下面的这个位置里头
其实是挂了小黄车的
有发现吗
很多人说老师啊
这种叫什么
这种的话呢因为它带货的载体是通过一个视频
所以我们把这种带货的形式把它称作为短视频带货
但是呢其实在整个未来的过程当中啊
单独的短视频带货这件事情其实已经不存在了
因为现在的整个系列的打法里头
其实短视频和商品卡是结合在一起的
意思就是你挂了小黄车以后
其实会变成投广告的一种素材
也就是说它是带动商品卡的
但是呢我们把这种形式称作为短视频带货
然后呢第三个的话呢大家在这里头搜索垃圾袋以后
你们会发现在底下的这个界面里头
你们可以看见是不是也有很多的人现在是在在干嘛
这边有位置
这边有空的位置
然后呢你们可以看见有很多人在直播
然后呢你们点开这个位置以后
大家可以看见这里头有卖货
因为它的载体其实是直播间
所以呢我们把它称作为直播带货
所以呢我们在运营的整个课程当中
其实是围绕着两大块来讲
哪两大块呢
一大块是通过商品卡把货给卖掉
通过店铺把货给卖掉
一种的话呢通过直播把货给卖掉
那短视频重不重要呢
短视频重要
但是呢短视频在整个运营板块当中
这个板块会和商品卡会结合到一起
也就是说短视频不是一个独立存在的载体
它是要通过短视频挂小黄车
然后把货给卖掉
好 其实呢这个呢是我们三大块
那好了那很多人呢说老师啊
那个课我可能也听了两周
但是呢我觉得我现在对于做抖音啊
我还是有一点点迷茫
说老师你看能不能帮我们把整个做抖音的基本思路呢
给大家呢来梳理一下
所以呢我们第一个板块呢
我们整个第一个板块当中呢
我先帮大家呢把整个做抖音的思路啊
给大家呢来梳理一下
我先帮大家看吧
好了那很多人呢会问我说他说老是啊你觉得我们做抖音的第一件事情是啥我也经常会问大家啊就是大家现在基础课都听完了那现在真正要开始去做一家抖音店铺了第一件事情是第一件事情是干啥之后呢很多人会一开口就说老是啊第一件事情是选品其实这个逻辑是不对的包括我们在整个抖音的第一节课里头我就在跟大家一起讲
其实大家未来真正去做的第一件事情不是选品大家做的第一件事情其实是选择行业很多人说老师为什么是选择行业呢大家其实可以来看一下就比如说大家就拿我们的整个服饰配件这个角度来看你们会发现服饰配件这里头它不是一个类目啊你们可以看见没有服饰配件的这个底下里头有什么帽子手套耳套微巾还有什么袖套还有什么配饰对吧比如说你们现在去做
看哪怕你们很多人说老师我们要做女装你们到女装里头以后你们会发现女装不是单纯的一个类目女装这个行业里头他有什么外套他有什么裙子他有什么卫衣他有什么T恤他有什么裤子对吧也就是说第一件事情大家其实不是选品第一件事情大家其实是什么呢第一件事情其实大家是在思考我到底要去做哪个行业哪个行业是有机会的所以呢第一件事情是分析行业判断哪个行业有机会
那么第二件事情是干嘛呢第二件事情是干嘛第二件事情是干嘛第二件事情是干嘛行业有了以后我们才会去讲第二件事情行业有了以后别说我现在就定下来了我要做维巾但是你们会发现维巾这个行业里头其实是有很多款式的维巾这个行业里头不是只有一种款式是这样的道理吧所以呢第二个维度行业定了才有选品行业不定你们选什么品呢
这么多品你们根本选不过来所以呢第二件事情的话呢其实呢讲选品其实呢在我们的整个系列课程当中尤其像今天
尤其像今天早上还有今天下午的课程当中呢我们其实两个核心就是教大家一个是做行业分析一个是选品就是前两件事情大家先不是去做抖音啊前两件事情大家是需要去思考我们我们要卖
我们要卖什么样的产品大家是去思考我们要做什么样的行业这个其实是第一步好那么讲完选品之后呢那很多人说老师那个选完评以后呢
选完评以后呢大家就知道接下来开始该干嘛
读到呢评选好了该干嘛开始定渠道啊大家接下来可以来定渠道在整个抖音里头其实
是未来精正有两种大家就是选择两种带货的方式哪两种带货的方式呢一种的话呢那就是通过整个直播去带货一种的话呢大家会发现通过什么来带货
一种是通过直播间来带货一种我刚才说了大家通过什么来带货
之后呢你们会发现一种的话呢就是通过商品卡来带货就是我通过
一种的话呢就是大家会发现我通过呢商品卡来带货
当然了很多同学问我啊
商品卡带货当然了很多同学问我很多同学问我什么问题呢
他说老师能不能跟我们去讲讲那个直播带货容易还是商品卡带货
更容易他说老师能不能跟我们去讲讲哪件事情更容易
很坦诚的跟大家去讲
真正来讲商品卡带货一定比直播带货更容易
为什么呢因为直播带货他要求的不仅仅是产品好
他要求的大家听过直播的课程以后你们会发现里头涉及到什么东西呢
涉及到场景搭建涉及到流量获取涉及到产品本身
也就是说他叫人货场
也就是说在场景里头可能对主播的能力要求
他其实是有的
所以呢我们现在如果说大家在准备开始接下来卖货时候呢
你们就得开始思考了
思考是什么呢
我到底是通过直播还是通过商品卡
他们俩运营的特点
他们俩运营的核心其实是
他们俩运营的思路
核心其实是不太一样的
所以呢很多人问我说
老师那你今天整个运营的课程当中
会跟大家去讲什么呢
其实呢运营的课程当中就讲三件事
第一件事情做什么行业
第二件事情那是什么样的产品
当然啦三天的商品卡里头呢
其实就讲两件事情
一商品卡的流量到底在哪里
二在商品卡里头
我怎么把这家一个产品做起来
我怎么去把一个店铺给做起来
大的思路就是这么几件事情
好了
那么大的思路呢给大家呢
大的思路呢给大家呢
理完了
那我们接下来呢
接下来呢
那就进入到我们整个运营的核心
我们跟大家呢需要来讲讲
那我们到底应该怎么去做
好了
那在整个今天早上的课程当中呢
我们其实呢会给大家去讲几个板块
那么哪几个板块呢
数据化选品里头啊
我们一般在讲这个板块的时候呢
我们是从几大块来讲的
那么我们是从哪几大块来讲的呢
第一大块里头呢
行业分析
大家到底应该去做什么样的行业分析
但是在整个行业分析里头
我们呢会从两个板块
哪两个板块呢
一个是基础的通用的
大家未来可能不及定在抖音卖货
你们未来可能在淘宝在多多卖货
它的通用的选款是怎么样来选的
那么第二个维度的话呢
大家毕竟所有的生意是在那来做呢
毕竟大家所有的生意呢是在抖音来做
那么在抖音里头到底什么样的产品是有机会的
所以呢整个第二个维度里头呢
我会跟大家来讲讲我们的整个进阶的选品
最主要是最主要的话呢是来讲讲在抖音里头我们到底卖什么
我们这个品到底能不能做
所以呢我们会讲这两个东西
那第二个维度的话呢我们会跟大家去讲什么东西呢
第二个维度的话呢我们会跟大家去讲卖什么产品
所以呢来讲选品
选品的思路呢我们主要呢讲三大类
第一大类就是平台要什么样的商品
平台已经告诉大家了
所以呢我们会跟大家去讲一下叫做商机商品
那么第二大类呢很多人去选品的思路是什么
很多人选品的思路呢也很简单粗暴
那么大家选品的思路是什么思路呢
第二种选品的思路呢很简单
那就是别人卖什么
我也啊
卖什么
跟款
但是如果说大家有真正意义上面去跟过款的
你们会发现一件事
发现一件什么事情呢
有些产品是跟着别人卖是能卖起来的
但是有些产品平台已经不给你们机会了
所以呢
在整个第二个版块当中呢
我们会跟大家呢去讲讲叫做跟款的思路
就是到底怎么去跟
第三个呢
很多人呢可能不是以跟款为主
在座的很多人可能自己是工厂自己是厂家
于是很多人就在想
比如说
很多人说老师我想卖棉拖鞋
那我想问大家一句话
你们猜啊
那我现在看到一款好卖的棉拖鞋
我现在在去做来不来得及作为一家工厂
我现在去做棉拖鞋来不来得及
来不来得及
为什么来不及
周呢不是流量已经分出去了
我告诉你是什么
所有大凡做棉拖鞋也好
做珊瑚容睡衣也好
这种行业真正的备货的时间是什么时候
备货的时间是8月份
为什么
原因是因为它生产的节奏没有那么快
它是工人一点一点做出来的
它现在去做
它就算卖的再好
它的工厂根本生产不出来
所以你们发现
而且好看的面料其实都已经耐空了
所以有一些行业它是要提前备货的
提前备货就不能根据别人的卖的好
我再去选择
所以第三个板块当中
我们去讲什么呢
第三个板块当中
我们跟大家呢
叫做根据热门属性来选择
属性来选择
还有种思路是什么呢
还有种思路就是大家可以去做报款搬运
什么叫报款搬运
就是有一些产品可能在多多
淘宝卖的很好
但是这个款在抖音还没有
于是我做了一件事情
我把淘宝还有多多的一些报款给它
搬运到我的抖音平台里头来
所以我们其实主要去讲报款打造的时候
报款选品的时候
我们其实就四种思路
一个是平台喜欢什么批
那么第二种思路是什么呢
更款
第三种思路就是行业的热门属性
第四种思路的话就是报款搬运
好
那么讲完这件事情以后
很多人说老师按这个板块中讲完了吗
我们一般讲课的逻辑是什么呢
讲三件事情
一个是工具
用什么样的工具
然后呢
第二件事情是数据
也就是说我的整个所有的系列课程
从刚一开始到现在这个阶段
我会跟很多人去讲一个点
就是做运营不要凭感觉
不要说我想做什么
不要说我喜欢什么
你想做什么
你们喜欢做什么
都不重要
重要的是什么
重要的是平台喜不喜欢
客户喜不喜欢
只有平台和客户喜欢
他才会给我机会
所以我们教大家的运营其实是数据分析的能力
然后第三件事情是什么
第三件事情的话其实是我如何的去选择
然后选择的逻辑是什么
所以我们所有东西从三个维度来讲
哪三个维度呢
第一个维度工具
第二个维度数据
第三个维度逻辑
所以整个今天早上的课程当中就讲三个板块
行业
原品再加上怎么去分析
好
那么进入到我们的整个正体
那我们呢首先呢去讲讲我们的整个行业分析
那么在那行业分析呢那首先来问大家第一句话
问大家第一句话是什么呢
就是在你们的心目当中什么样的行业是有机会的
在你们的心目当中就是什么样的行业给你们留有机会
什么样的行业大家是可以去做的
从基本的基础的逻辑上来讲
你们觉得什么样的行业大家觉得可以做
什么样的行业有机会
基础的逻辑上来讲
什么样的行业可以做
什么样的行业有机会啊
你们会通过哪些维度去判断一个行业
能不能做
比如说我们曾经有同学问过这样一个问题
问过一个什么问题呢
他说老师我想做
他说老师我想做个什么东西呢
我忘记那个是什么样的产品了
那么我们直接搜一下吧
他说老师我想做那个
他说我想做连衣裙
我想做一种小众类目的连衣裙
什么连衣裙呢
他说那个
他说你看有亲子装有大马装
他说我想做闺蜜装连衣裙
他说他就想做闺蜜穿的这种连衣裙
你们觉得合适还是不合适
合适还是不合适
当然呢
判断一个东西合不合适呢
我们不是从嘴上去说
第一个维度判断它合不合适的本身
首先它有没有市场吗
它有没有市场容量
它有没有市场的基本的热度
所以我去选择一个行业
我啥都不去讲
那第一件事情呢
肯定得要有市场容量
意思就是这个行业它得要有市场
市场容量的话呢
我们未来会讲很多的工具
最简单的去分析有没有市场呢
大家可以用哪个工具呢
给大家推荐一个工具
这个其实我们一会还会来讲
那么什么工具呢
巨量算数
其实现在的整个巨量算数已经下架了
但是你们可以在百度里头呢
你们可以直接的去搜索巨量算数
然后呢
巨量算数呢升级了
升级成什么东西呢
升级成抖音指数
大家呢去点击一下它
然后在这个里头你们去搜嘛
搜什么闺蜜连异群
大家呢可以去搜一下
搜完以后
这都都没有
那你们告诉我
市场都没有热度的东西
这个怎么做
意思就是做了一夜
白做
好了
那比如说我现在想做什么东西呢
那么比如说我现在想做连衣裙
我想做女装
很多同学对女装很感兴趣
我想做连衣裙
我想做女装
你看这个热度是有的
你们一点击到这个位置里头
大家可以看到
连衣裙的整个热度是14000多
有热度吧
那你们觉得女装能不能做
女装能不能做
女装能做吗
我告诉你们
中小卖家去做女装
你们没有一条路
你们只有一条路叫死路
很多人问我说老师为什么
女装这个行业的转化率只有2%
说错了
0.2%
0.2%你们知道是什么意思吗
就是100个人看了以后
只有0.2个人买
那钱是一样花
因为你们要人你们就要有广告
钱是一样花
但是你卖出去东西会
你卖出去东西会
会少啊
是这样的道理吧
所以呢你们发现这个
而且呢我觉得这样这个东西还不是最可怕的
你们要最可怕的什么吗
今年双十一抖音的官方数据
女装的退货率是多少呢
女装的退货率是85%
你们知道吗
女孩子一般怎么买衣服
女孩子都不是一件一件买
女孩子买衣服就是一口气买五件
然后五件里头
薪钱好可能留一件
薪钱不好五件全给退了
而且再加上促单
也就是说中小卖家去做女装
如果说你们去做的行业
它的退货率它的转化率如此低
就意味着你们要大量的成本
你需要囤大量的货
如果说你们已经做服装做了很多年了
我说就真喜欢你们都不一定能挣钱
况且
大家在刚开始起步想去做女装
其实很难
所以呢
第二个维度呢
很多人问我说老师你在讲啥
第二个维度里头呢
我其实是在跟大家去讲准备去做一个行业的时候
去看看这个行业的转化率
去看看这个行业的退货率
去选择的行业
相对来讲你们选择一个行业能不能做
这个行业总转化率总不能太
转化率不能太低
然后呢
退货率不能太高
太高的行业
退货率的行业
其实你们是做不了的
好
那问一下大家
你们觉得曾志茂能不能做
曾志茂
女孩子
男孩子在野心
女孩子在的
冬天这个季节
曾志茂能不能做
能不能做
好像说
老师
曾志茂可以试一下
曾志茂可以去做
我们来看一下曾志茂能不能做
然后呢
我们在这个位置里头呢
我们可以直接的去搜索曾志茂
然后呢
搜索完曾志茂以后呢
不要看这么看几天的数据
你们可以把它以一个周期来看
以什么周期来看呢
比如说我们现在呢
从从二三年的十二月份
或者说我们从二三年的九月份
我们看到什么时候呢
我们看到
我们看到今天为止
我们看到一月五号
大家其实可以看一下
我们现在就从二三年看到
现在你们可以看到
从二三年开始
曾志茂什么时候大盘就开始下滑了
你们看到没有
看到了吗
你忘记
十二月二十号一过
大家看见没有
大盘开始下滑
然后你们再去看二四年
二四年是什么时候开始下滑
你们看见没有
十二月二十九号以后
大盘就开始一路下滑
下滑
很明显今年的珍芝茂
大家一眼看过去以后已经到达
差不多就算是已经到达
峰值了
你们知道大盘下滑意味着什么吗
大家知道大盘下滑意味着什么吗
之后呢
大家很多人没有做过周期性的爆款
但是如果说大家做过周期性的爆款
你们会发现大盘下滑意味着什么
大盘下滑意味着你们同行都在打价格战
你们会发现你今天
拿的货可能你第二天会发现同行卖的价格
比你今天拿的价格会更低
你们会发现你们努力的去做广告
但是你们的数据却一天不如
一天这款商品是推不起来的
明白我的意思吗
而且呢
二大家想把一款产品给它做起来
所有的产品去推的时候
它是有周期的
我们去打一个品
最起码得打三周到三四周时间
第一次就是我现在看完这个品
可能还行
但是有没有一种可能性
等我打完三四周
等我打完三四周以后
这个品
它开始下滑了
有没有这种可能性
有
所以呢
你们可以看见大盘
比如说你看我现在开始打
等我打完以后
一个品打完
25号了
你看见没有
真正帽的市场都已经
没了
所以呢
我们得要判断一个行业能不能做
我在这个位置里头呢
得要看
趋势
然后大家都想做市场大的
我想问的是你们想做
大卖家想不想做
很多已经在做抖音的
他们想不想做
他们肯定也想啊
而且的话呢
他们肯定比你们经验也丰富
比你们更
有钱呢
所以呢
你们面临的问题是什么呢
我们刚开始做抖音的时候
不要去想那种大的行业
越大的行业
大家可能
挤不进去
整个市场和行业没有给你们留太多的机会
所以呢
我当然希望我能做的行业是相对来讲竞争会更小一点
我们呢
希望来做的行业呢是竞争更小的行业
好了
所以呢
从基本的角度来讲呢
我们自己在做一个行业的时候呢
我们最起码在考虑几件事
一有没有市场
别人家能不能卖货
二好不好卖
三
趋势
四
竞争
小
好
但是我们前面讲到这个东西
他只是凭感觉去说呀
他不是
他不是真实的数据对吧
所以呢我们接下来呢跟大家去讲讲我们在抖音里头
我们怎么获得这些数据
我们怎么去分析一个行业
那比如说吧我们就拿一个行业给大家来举例子
拿哪个行业来给大家举例子呢
然后
我们呢就拿我们的整个服饰配件这个行业里头
我们跟大家呢来举例子
我们一般呢是怎么样去分析
一个类目呢到底能做还是不能做
好了
那第一个呢我们跟大家呢来讲讲我们的整个工具
我们一般在做整个行业分析的时候呢
我们会用到的工具呢是三个工具来做整个行业分析
哪三个工具来做行业分析呢
第一个工具的话呢大家呢可以呢直接去
大家可以到你们的整个店铺的后台
然后在你们的整个店铺的后台里头
大家会发现这里头是不是有一个电商罗盘
然后呢电商罗盘点进去以后
大家可以其实可以看到这个里头他其实是有一个市场
市场里头点进去以后
大家其实可以看到这个位置里头是不是有一个
这个位置里头是不是有一个
有一个类目盖矿啊
然后大家在这个里头选择你们的大类目
选择完你们大类目以后呢
底下就有所有的细分类目
大家就可以看见所有的细分类目
他的交易额
他的成交占比
他的成交人数是不是都有了
所以呢
第一个我们想看一个行业
基本的市场在哪里呢
在罗盘
罗盘里头有一个市场
市场里头有一个类目挖掘
大家可以在这个位置里头呢
选择你们的类目
这个是第一个工具啊
大家可以来拍一下照片
我们一般呢
通过这个工具是用来干嘛的呢
这个工具的话呢
他主要是分析这个市场
有没有说有没有成交人数是多少
成交的体量是多少
有没有给我
有没有给我留
有没有给我留更多的机会
所以呢
这个其实是第一个
这个东西呢叫
这个东西叫内幕概况
然后第二个很多人说老师我想看一个行业
转化率高不高
比如说我想看帽子帽子这个行业转化率好不好
所以呢
第二个工具
我们一般呢
给大家介绍的是什么工具呢
就是我要看一个行业的转化率去哪里看
大家呢还是去我们的整个市场
然后呢
在整个市场里头大家会发现这个位置里头是不是有个东西叫搜索榜单
在搜索榜单里头大家先选择大的方向自己选中
然后呢
比如说我想看真知帽那你们就在这个位置里头搜索真知帽
大家可以看到搜索完真知帽以后你们可以看到真知帽这个行业
你们看见没有转化率是多少
真知帽这行业转化率15%到20%
那说明真知帽这个行业是
但是还行好卖吗
大家看完以后基本上会买
所以呢第二个工具是什么工具呢
我们一般看一个行业的转化率怎么样呢
它是通过市场还是在罗盘里头
然后呢上面有一个叫做搜索榜单
然后呢选择你们自己的类目
输入你们的产品
然后呢在底下的这个位置里头就可以看到转化率
所以呢这是大家要拍到的第二张照片
我们到哪里去分析
一个行业的一个产品的转化率怎么样
怎么去分析这个行业呢
好不好做
大家可以拍一下照片
就是大家一定要知道
在我们整个未来所有的运营的过程当中
我说的最多的一句话就是
未来哪个款好卖
不要凭感觉
你们不能有自己的感觉
只要有自己的感觉
哎呀
说了做了这么多年电商
跟你们去讲讲讲一个我们很惨淡的故事
就是有一段时间我对自己的审美产生了怀疑
就是我觉得好看的款一定推不起来
我觉得这个款长得特别楼特别难看
它就卖爆了
我甚至有一段时间我都在想一件事情
是不是我这个审美有问题
后来我释怀了
没办法
你要放弃自己的审美
你们喜欢没用
你们喜欢不代表客户
喜欢做运营要放弃
我喜欢
所有东西都基于
对
所有东西都基于数据和客户来
所以呢
第二个维度的话呢
大家呢
是我们他
那第三个维度
刚才说很多人说老师那个
呃趋势到哪里分析
其实我刚才已经跟大家去看了
趋势的话呢
其实是在我们的
大家可以看到没有
你们可以直接的去百度里头搜一个那个
巨量算术
其实巨量算术已经改版了
改版的名字的话呢
它叫抖音指数
所以呢
我们现在用到的工具呢
主要是三大类的工具
是我们呢
会用到的
哪三大类工具呢
第一大类工具的话呢
是在整个市场
是到我们的整个罗盘
然后呢
里头呢
它会有一个市场
市场里头呢
它会有一个叫做
类目概况
这个的话呢
最主要是看
概况
这个最主要的话呢
是看整个市场容量的
然后呢
去看
成交键数的
容量和成交键数
容量呢
和成交键数
第二个的话呢
我们去哪呢
还是罗盘的市场里头
它会有一个什么呢
搜索榜单
榜单
大家呢
可以搜索你们的产品
这个的话呢
最主要是看
转化率的
第三个的话呢
其实是我们的整个抖音指数
巨量算数已经下线了
但是呢
以前的话呢
你们可以呢
叫巨量算数
大家可以到百度里头
刚才大家看见了
我们去看这个东西的时候是在百度里头
刚才大家看见我是在百度里头直接去搜的巨量算数
然后呢
你们点进去以后
你们就可以看到整个行业的基本的这种趋势
好了
所以呢
我们一般用到的工具呢
这是三个
那好了
那来实战的
讲讲那我们怎么去分析一个行业好不好做呢
好
那我刚才也跟大家去讲了
我说
我们用到这工具
好
那你看
我们去点击市场
点击我们这个里头的内幕概况
然后呢
我在这个里头
你看
我想选择服饰配件这个行业
你看这里头是不是就有
所有的这些内幕呀
那么
问题来了
这里都有这么多数据
那你看刚才的这个位置里头去讲了
讲了什么乱七八糟的
什么市场容量之类的
那这个东西该怎么办呢
首先呢
第一件事情
我先把
我先啥话都不讲
我先把这个表格先给它
复制下来
因为放在这个位置里头
我没办法去
分析
你们能明白我这意思吗
所以呢
我把这张表格呢
给它复制一下
复制一下以后呢
打开我们的表格
然后呢
把刚才我们
坐在这个位置里头
所有的东西呢
我们给它
粘贴到这个位置里头来
把这张表格呢
给它
粘到这
你看
好了
这个里头呢
我就把它
所有的数据呢
就给它复制好了
但是问题来了
我现在要分析市场容量
我现在要分析竞争
但是大家可以看见
这个中间有很多
乱七八糟的
这个什么
你们看见没有
这个中间有什么
这种区间值
然后你们发现
这个位置还有什么
这种多余的空格
而且我想要的
有些数据
它在这个位置里头
它可能还没有
比如说竞争这个东西
它也没有
所以呢
拿复制好的张表格
你得先处理
大家怎么去处理呢
你们发现
第一件事情是
把上面的这个带有空格的这个位置
我先给它删除掉
第二件事情是干嘛呢
第二件事情
大家会发现
我想分析市场容量
什么是市场容量呢
你们看见没有
市场容量
无非就是成交人数是市场容量
成交件数是市场容量
但是这个市场容量
它这个区间值啊
区间值是不是不好分析啊
所以第二件事情是要把所有的区间值给它变成
变成一个具体的数值
那怎么做呢
其实呢
这个在讲基础课的时候呢
有教过大家去做
之后呢
我们其实是用Counter加F
这两个键一起按
我们是怎么样来做的呢
然后我们的话呢
其实呢
是把Counter和F键
两个一起按到一起Counter键和F键
然后呢
这个位置里头
接下来我们干嘛呢
这里头有个替换
我把
我把N一个叫做星号横杠
很多人说老师星号横杠什么意思
星号横杠的意思就是横杠前面东西我都不要了
我就问星号横杠
如果说你们想保留的是前面的
那你们就按横杠
横杠
星号意思就是横杠后面的这些东西我就都不要了
明白我的意思吗
所以呢
我一般的话呢我们是前面的不要了
我留一个最高的数值
然后替换成什么呢
替换成没有
然后呢点击全部替换
大家会发现我就完成了一个动作
完成了一个什么动作呢
我就把这个区间值变成了一个具体的数值
然后呢很多人说老师接下来可以数据分析了吧
也还不行
为啥还不行呢
原因是大家在这个位置里头我们要分析啥呢
我们一般呢会分析
成交的人数
但是大家一眼看过去以后
你们会发现
所有的这些人数背后都带了一个万字
这个万字是没办法做数据分析的
我得把万字变成
零
明白我的意思吗
但是我能不能直接替换呢
不行
因为你们看见没有
这里都有7.5万
如果说我直接替换
它还是7.5
所以呢
我们一般的做法是
把这行的东西呢
给它复制一下
你们可以呢
点击复制一下
然后呢
找一张新的表格
把所有的万字都去掉
点击它
Counter+F
然后呢
替换
把所有的万都替换成没有
然后呢
第二个的话呢
是干嘛呢
在这个基础上
在乘上多少呢
然后
它就等于前面的这个数字呢
乘上
1万
好了
我点击完它
然后呢
你们可以看见从上到下可以拉下来
或者说你们会快捷键的
底下有个黑色加号
你们可以弄下来
大家可以看见没有
我是不是就把这种带文字的全部都变成数字了呀
然后呢
我可以把这边的这些所有的数字给它复制一下
但是到这边来以后
我点击
我点击这个地方呢
我可以直接的粘贴
但是大家会把你粘贴完以后就成了乱码
为什么会成为乱码呢
原因是因为你在这块粘贴的时候
这边是有公式的
你粘贴过来以后就没公式了
所以大家在这边复制完粘贴的时候
一定得把它粘贴成
看见没有上面有个东西叫做粘贴成
数字
好了
你们看见没有
我就把成交人数变成数字了
然后呢
我还需要看什么数据呢
我还需要看动销商品数
所以一样的动作
我为了方便
我
我就
不给大家一一的也是
我快速的给大家去做这个动作
粘贴到这
counter+F
把1T换成
没有
然后在这个数字的基础上
然后呢
在这个数字的基础上
来乘上1万
这个2500是不对的
2050.25万
这个2500得删掉
好了
然后呢
把这张数字呢
给它复制一下
然后呢
到这个位置里头呢
给它
粘贴成数字
好
大家会发现这张表格我就做完了
那好了
那张表格处理完以后
我接下来开始干嘛呢
我得我得看一下这里头有没有我要的东西
我判断一个行业能不能做的时候呢
刚才说了几件事情
一市场容量是有的
成交人数就是市场容量
第二件事情
竞争环境是什么
所以这个里头还要加入一个新的指标
叫虚贡比
虚贡比等于什么呢
虚贡比等于成交人数除上动销商品数
意思就是我希望我做的行业
成交的人数多
但是跟我抢这个市场的人少
所以虚贡比这个数值越大
它就代表竞争是越小的
你们有意思吗
而且大家不会说在这个里头
在这个地方看到虚贡比
未来在整个抖音很多地方你们都会看到虚贡比这个指标
未来大家会到哪里看到虚贡比呢
然后未来大家可能会去选品
选品的时候会到哪呢
会到商品里头
它会有一个商机中心
在商机中心里头
大家点进去
看到我这里头的某一个品的时候
比如说你们点开这款产品的时候
然后大家看见没有
这个位置是不是就有一个东西叫虚贡比啊
意思就是虚贡比这个指标不是我们给大家设计出来的
是平台在很多地方
看见没有有虚贡比这个指标
包括大家未来在看一个行业数据的时候
你们去哪里看呢
然后你们到这里头去看一个行业数据的时候
大家可以看见没有
他在判断这个行业是不是一个蓝海市场
你看见没有
判断这个行业是不是蓝海市场的时候
他也用的是需求供给比
然后什么是虚贡比呢
你们看见没有
购买的用户数比上动销商品数
看见没有
你看购买的用户数比上动销商品数
是不是就是虚贡比啊
所以呢
在我准备去做数据分析之前啊
我们呢
得去把我们的整个表格呢
来进行
进行处理
那么刚才去做了哪些动作处理呢
一我们删除了基本的空格
然后呢
第二间位置
我们把区间值
变成了具体的数值
然后呢
你们会发现
我把文字变成了
我们把所有上面的文字变成了具体的数字
然后呢
第四件事情
我们干嘛了呢
你们会发现
我插入了一个东西叫虚共笔
虚共笔等于什么呢
虚共笔等于
叫做成交人数
人数来比上我们的整个动销商品数
而且呢
这个数值越大代表竞争越小
这个地方呢
代表这个市场是有机会的
这个市场是蓝海的
好了
那表格有了以后呢
那很多人说老师那个我们具体怎么去分析
我们如何去选择呢
其实呢我们在如何选择上面呢
我们跟大家刚才其实有跟大家去讲
我说商家可以分成
大家的商家的可以分成两大类呀
哪两大类呢
第一大类
如果说大家是小白卖家
大家才刚开始做抖音
你们去选择的时候
选择什么行业呢
如果说大家是中小卖家
大家去选择说呢
第一个维度选择竞争小的
第二个维度选择转化率
最起码在5%以上的
5%以下的行业
不用去碰了
碰了也没有机会
太难做了
成本太高了
然后第三件事情是有有一定的市场
然后呢
有一定的市场
第四件事情呢
趋势总体的趋势是稳定
总体的它的趋势呢
是稳定
最好是最好这个趋势是能上升
那就更好
所以中小卖家在选择的时候呢
是这些维度
就是竞争项
转化高
有市场
而且呢趋势稳定
如果很多人说老师我是大卖家
我不缺钱
我就是想做
所以呢
如果说是大卖家在选择的时候
选择什么呢
就选择两个东西
一个东西是什么呢
一个东西就是有市场
市场容量大
就是交易人数多
第二个维度的话呢
第二个维度
考虑趋势
大卖家也要考虑预计趋势
逆势而上的事情是做不了的
所以呢
选择趋势
好的
这可以
好
大的方向有了
那么我们给大家的去看看我们是怎么去分析的
你看这样表哥已经放到这了
那么虚共比我刚才知道了
虚共比是怎么得到的呢
当刚才大家看到了虚共比是用成交人数
用成交人数除上了动销商品数
这个是不是就是虚共比啊
然后呢
如果说你想把这个公式复制下来怎么办呢
能它原本是空心的十字
变成十心的十字以后
你们双击
大家看见没有
我现在所有东西我就得到了
好
那么我们先来把这个行业里头
我竞争小的
然后呢
我先把这个行业里竞争小的给他选择出来
你看把第一行选中
然后呢
做数据
做筛选
把竞争小的这个行业呢
我给他做一个降续排列
大家可以看到我在这个位置里头
我是不是就可以把
你看我总共是18
我把竞争最小的前9名
大家可以看到底下的这个位置
这个有个9
然后我给他涂一下颜色
意思就是
我就把我们这个行业竞争最小的前9名
我是不是就筛选出来了
然后第二件事情考核的是什么呢
第二件事情
那我也希望我的这个行业
他最起码有一定的成交
所以你们可以看到
我在这个位置里头
把成交人数做一个
项序排列
然后你们再给他涂一个前9个
成交多的前9名
然后大家给他涂一个
颜色
然后你们去按照点开他
上面有个叫做按颜色筛选
点一下按颜色筛选
然后呢
点一下这个里头
按颜色筛选
意思是我的第一个工作就做完了
第一工作里头呢
我就选择出来了
竞争又小
而且能够带来成交的行业
大家看见没有
竞争小的是什么呢
你看鞋包
皮带
然后呢
帽子
围巾
腰带
手套
防护数据什么DIY编制包
袖扣
这个就是
又有市场
而且竞争还
小的行业
但是我能不能就决定了呢
我不行
因为我还得看一下这个行业的
转化率怎么样
对吧
所以呢
我们在这个位置里头呢
我会还会加入两个东西
加入哪两个东西呢
一个东西的话呢
叫做转化率
我希望我做的这个行业总体的
趋势是好的
所以呢
他要借助我们的第二个工具
那么我们要做第二个工具是什么呢
那看一下啊
总体行业
总体的这个
那么首先第一个叫鞋包
那鞋包的转化率怎么样呢
到哪个工具里头可以看呢
然后要看转化率到市场的这个里头
大家看见没有
上面会有一个叫搜索榜单
你们在这里头先选择自己搭的类目
然后呢
你们去搜索
比如说叫做鞋包
那我就去搜索一下
或者说我在这个位置头呢
我就选择一个鞋包这个行业
然后呢
我看看这个这个行业里头到底是些什么东西啊
鞋包这个行业里头呢
哦
他这里头包含了一些什么鞋电之类的
主要是以鞋电为主
对吧
你看
大家看见没有
鞋电的转喊率是多少
你们发现就选最高的就可以了
百分之六十五
当然了我为了给大家讲课我不所有的都分析
我就给大家分析四个给你们看看怎么去选择
可以吗
然后呢那第二个帽子我们呢再来看一下这个行业里头帽子的转化率是多少
然后呢你们去点击一下所有的帽子
然后呢帽子的转化率是大概在多少
你发现不对转化率转化率大家看见没有20%
所以如果说鞋垫和帽子上来讲我肯定鼓励大家做鞋垫
因为鞋垫的转化率更更高
然后呢你们发现围巾丝巾那我们在这个位置里头呢
我们我们在这个位置里头大家可以去搜索一下我们的整个围巾
然后呢你们可以来看到你们看到没有围巾的转化率大概在多少
然后呢你们可以看到围巾的转化率的话呢差不多是在20%左右
那你确实围巾和帽子围巾和帽子差不多然后呢20%然后呢腰带皮带
然后呢你们去搜索一下腰带皮带的转化率是多少
然后现在百分之四十你看平均下来基本上都是百分之四十左右
对吧
所以呢腰带皮带的转化率呢在百分之四十左右
然后呢再看一个那个手套
然后呢大家可以看一眼手套的转化率是多少啊
然后呢你们可以看到手套的整个转化率呢是百分之二十五
大家可以看见我现在是不是就可以进一步的缩小范围
我一眼就可以看到在这四个行业里头
哪一个行业的转化率是更
哪一个行业的转化率是更高的
然后呢那我除去这个东西以外
我再去加上一个东西分析
我再加上一个什么分析呢
叫趋势分析对吧
那我们来看看这些东西哪个可以做
好了那我们呢直接的用我们的整个巨量算数来
然后呢我们来看一下那个鞋垫
鞋垫我一眼去看一下鞋垫的趋势
鞋垫有淡忘季吗
鞋垫没有淡忘季你们可以看见
除非说到过年是淡忘季
但是基本上来讲鞋垫你们可以看见
过完年也是忘季
你看见没有鞋垫是不是过完年也是忘季啊
他只有到春节期间是淡季
剩下全年基本上
你看全年没有所谓的淡忘季
真正的鞋垫只有看见没有
只有什么时候是淡季
看到没有什么时候是淡季
只有夏天是淡季
那意思就是鞋垫我们现在开始做
我最起码我可以做到明年7月份
趋势来讲一定是稳定的
对吧
然后呢我刚才看到了帽子
我们来看一下我们总体的帽子
然后呢搜索完一下帽子以后
大家可以看见帽子的话
一过完年
大家可以看见下半年是冒季
12月份一过大盘就开始跌了
然后你们看见9月份开始上涨
那意思就是帽子接下来肯定是
帽子接下来开始进入到什么季节了
衰退
然后呢维巾呢
维巾呢维巾也是一样的对吧
你看维巾也接下来肯定是下滑
是不是啊
然后呢
腰带呢
腰带来讲
全年并没有所谓的
带旺季整个都是一条
线是这样的道理吧
所以呢
你们在这个位置里头大家可以其实可以看一下所有趋势还有手套
那么我们手套也来
看一下
那么我们一眼看过去以后
手套
哦
手套也是
冬季为主
你看见没有
九月份开始手套开始爆发
你看见八九月份开始手套开始
手套现在也
吃了
所以呢
如果说从这个角度上来讲
鞋垫是比较稳定的
然后呢
你们会发现腰带相对来说是比较稳定的
剩下的这几个是下滑
其实当我把这些东西放在这的时候
大的方向上来讲不需要我去跟大家去讲
你们就知道
我如果说在这些行业里头我要选择做点啥
最起码
如果说要做帽子围巾手套
那基本上得到
基本上得到
明年的8月份是这样的道理吧
也就是说现在这个趋势来看
鞋垫还有腰带是我可以去
做的
大家可以看见我在现在在教大家分析行业的时候
没有一句话是我告诉大家
我觉得什么行业好做
不要我觉得什么行业好做
是大的市场
大的大的方向上来讲好不好做
所以呢在这个位置里头我们是怎么教大家分析的呢
你们会发现中小卖家在这些维度分析里头呢分析几个点就可以了
哪几个点呢
第一个先选择竞争小的
因为你们抢不过那些大卖家
第一个点就是竞争小
第二个点是什么呢
第二个点最好是转化不低于百分之
刚才说了转化不低于百分之五
然后呢第三个点的话呢有一定的市场
市场也关键
然后呢第四个点是什么呢
第四个点趋势上来讲
它正好这个趋势是在上升的
拍下照片
我们我特别喜欢跟大家说的一句话
什么就是我给大家去讲课
不是讲所谓的理论
大家其实可以看到我刚才所有的判断一个行业好不好做
没有一句话是
没有一句话是我说这个行业好不好做
我是拿工具给大家拉到这个位置里头
让你们去看这个行业好不好做
包括你们问我是老师维巾现在还能不能做维巾怎么做
维巾已经过气了
也就是说在服饰配件里头你们可以看见鞋边的可以做做
皮带腰带可以做做其他的已经过季了
很多人前两天有同学问我说老师那个对联能不能做
对联能不能做
对联的话呢就送你们一句话赶紧吧
因为你们可以看到到1月底是巅峰
今年过年会稍微的迟一点点
意思就是对联接下来就会进入到一个高速爆发的阶段
意思就是你抓上了就抓上了
你抓不上也就抓不上了
但是呢对联我担心的是什么
你们卖的好的款式会瞬间的没有货
因为到最后的时候大家就只给自己供货
尤其好卖的款
就是你们手里头能卖的最连都是一些通货
所以我担心的是这个
但是呢像年久跟你们去讲啊
那个所有的电商年前是最好做的
大家可能不知道就是我们每年到这一期讲课的时候
我都会做一个点
年前是你们弯道超车最好的机会
不要那么早回家去过年
因为就这段机会
大家都想着回家过年
所以商家少
广告费也低
这个季节里头哪些东西可以去做呢
节庆里的各种各样的东西
你们不一定去做对联啊
你们可以去做什么呢
新年的挂件
新年的摆件
新年的贴纸这些东西行不行
行
而且你们还有什么东西可以做呢
清洁工具
因为到年底了
大家接下来都得开始
打扫厨
打扫个卫生吧
清洁工具
还有什么呢
到过年了你们这次买果盘水果盘这些东西其实都是年前比较一个旺盛的
然后呢很多人说老师鞋帽有没有机会
说句真心话
围巾还有一波
新年围巾红围巾
然后呢
袜子也有一波机会
袜子和内衣是什么呢
红袜子
红内衣
到新年绝对都
都火爆
这个是中国人的
传统
这个意思就是现在年前就只是他最后一波机会
就是围绕着
所有的生意都是围绕着
新年来
新年一过完就到了春季
春季的话呢
有几个机会
那就是夏季的上新了
对吧
开学季了
这个都是你们可以去考虑的
就是大家在分析一个行业的时候
你们可以大概的思考一下
然后再去验证
但是更多的不是凭嘴上
更多的事情是要看数据
就是我不停的跟大家去调
就是我的理念里头做了这么多年运营
我所有的理念里头
就是所有今天给大家去讲的所有东西
不要凭感觉
嘴上说的东西都没有用
好了
所以呢
在整个第一个板块当中呢
我们其实是想让大家知道的是想给大家讲的
讲的是什么东西呢
叫做行业的基础分析
主要分析
几件事情
用了三个工具
好
这样分析够了没有
够了没有
这么分析够了没有
不够啊
因为大家是在抖音平台里头做生意
我现在只是分析大的方向和趋势
那么你们还会面临什么东西呢
比如说有没有这样种可能性
比如说万一鞋变
人家卖两毛钱一双怎么办
你们根本没有
利润啊
而且
他卖的销量这么多
我也不知道他通过哪个渠道卖起来
比如说
我不用做我不会做直播
但是我的通行全部都是通过直播做起来的
有没有这种可能性
太有这种可能性了
所以呢
第二个维度呢
我们跟大家呢
来讲讲
叫做行业的进阶分析
来
大家先拍张照片啊
拍张照片呢
我往下来讲
大家先拍一下照片
好
那么第二个维度里头呢
我们跟大家呢
来讲讲我们的行整个行业的这种进阶分析
好
很多人说老师啊
进阶分析分析哪些维度啊
我你先讲讲呗
我们进阶分析在分析几件事情
第一件事情
我想知道别人的这个东西是通过哪个渠道卖掉的
我得想想这件事情我能不能做
比如说别人都是通过直播卖掉的
我就得在想我会不会直播
如果我不会在短时间内我不会直播
那我这个屏我就先不碰
哪个东西你们会做
你们就先做哪一个
说到这儿
问一下你们啊
问一下你们
做生意是要补足短板还是发挥优势
我告诉你
所有的东西啊
你们看到的这个社会啊
是一个什么社会呢
都不要拿自己的短板
不要是补足自己的短板
补短板的时间周期会很长
你们知道吗
别人都是拿优势跟你的短板去比
别说会做哪个就先做哪个
先把自己优势先发挥出来
所以呢
第二个维度呢
我们一般先分析渠道
第一个别人是通过哪个渠道
把货卖出去的
我能不能去做
那么第二个维度分析什么东西呢
第二个维度分析
这个渠道的这个渠道的
完了呢我们整个渠道里头的行业的前20名的销量吧
如果说别人第一名一天只能卖10单
第一名如果说一天只能卖10单
那你们你们最牛也就是一天卖10单
就会有位置
人说第一名如果说一天只卖10单
那你们是不是也最多一天也就是只有卖10单啊
所以呢你们会发现
分析一下行业前20名的销量
看看你们有没有机会
然后呢第三件事情是什么呢
第三件事情看看啥
看看这个东西它总体的这种价格带
分析一下这个东西还有没有还有没有利润
意思就是没利润我辛苦巴拉的做半天都是被挣钱吧
所以呢我们会做三四个维度分析渠道
然后呢前20名的销量
然后呢价格带还有利润
二那我们这个东西一般用什么样的工具来实现呢
上面这个工具有在用啊
就上面这个罗盘这里头的工具呢有在用
就这个工具我们还会去用
但是现在它的作用是什么呢
它的作用变成了两个作用
一个是分析渠道
一个是分析价格带
二那这个位置里头我还有什么工具呢
在罗盘里头呢
它会有一个叫做商品榜单
在商品榜单里头我可以在整个商品榜单
你看这个里头它会有个商品榜单
我要做我要做商品卡
我就在这个位置里头我可以选择商品卡
然后我可以看到商品卡的商家他们的数据
明白我的意思吗
所以呢我可以看到我们这个行业的钱
我可以看到我们这个行业的钱
20名他们到底能不能卖货
成交金额是多少
成交件数是多少
所以呢看见没有
第二个工具是商品榜单
我可以看到他们的总体的这种销量
然后呢第三个工具是看具体他们卖的什么样的价格
所以呢你们可以看到在罗盘里头
这个里头有一个细致的分析一个类目
盖框是大致的
大家看见没有这个是不是有个叫做类目
挖掘
盖框是大致的
比如说我现在就想分析鞋带或者是鞋垫
你看见我点击这个位置里头
它是详细的去分析鞋带或者是鞋垫
你们可以看见
大家卖了什么样的价格
什么样的属性
好卖
你们看见没有
所以呢
在这个里头呢又是三个工具
一个是类目概括
一个是商品榜单
一个是类目挖掘
类目挖掘的话呢
是细致的行业数据分析
数据分析
所以呢
这个里头有三个
好
那我们呢
就拿这三个呢
来给大家去讲讲
怎么判断一个行业呢
能不能做
好了
那第一个维度里头
我去分析一个行业呢
先进行的第一个维度呢
叫做销售渠道分析
好
那我们来看看
就刚才我说到的鞋变
那鞋变能不能做呢
那么大家到你们的整个电商罗盘里头来点击市场
然后大家看见没有
市场里头是不是这个地方有个类目挖掘呀
然后呢
你在上面的这个位置里头你就选择
大家既然都说想去做鞋变
那你们就在这个位置里头呢
选择这个鞋变
然后呢
你可以看见
我在这个位置是不是就选择鞋变
点击一下鞋变
然后呢往底下这个位置里头去看
然后呢一眼看过去以后
你们会发现百分之三十四是通过谁卖出去的
商品卡百分之三十三是通过短视频
百分之二十六因此就是做不做直播都无所谓
甚至我都可以完全不做直播
因为主要就是通过商品卡和短视频卖出去的
我不做直播有关系没关系
没关系
但是呢我们一般看很多人说怎么判断这个行业要不要去做这件事情
一看看这个渠道能不能达到20%以上
或者这个渠道7天的营业额能不能达到多少呢
别一天想在什么1000万呢多少万的事情
这个7天如果说这个渠道里头能达到50万以上的营业额
那就说明这个渠道是给我留有机会的明白我的意思吗
所以呢大家可以看到啊
类目销售渠道分析其实是在哪里呢
是在类目概况里头怎么判断这个渠道
这个渠道能不能做呢
两件事情
一这个渠道的销售占比能不能达到20%
占比能不能达到20%
或者就这两个条件只要达到一个条件就行了
或者这个销售渠道
渠道它的整个七天的营业额能不能达到
五十万以上
整个行业七天的营业额能达到五十万
在我的心目当中就能分我的一杯羹
明妙的意思吗
这个里头我们再说明一下啊
我们在这个里头说的不是说这两个条件都要达到
是这两个条件只要有一个条件能达到
那就说明这个渠道我是可以做的
所以呢你们可以在这个位置里头
抖音版反正无非就是做三件事情
要么是做商品卡
要么是做短视频
要么是做直播
那最简单的就是商品卡和短视频
对吧那这两个件事情呢你们能不能做好
那行那么看完这东西以后呢问题来了那第二件事情看什么呢
那第二件事情得看看人家销量有多少啊
看看商品榜单里头所以呢
第二个的话呢你们会见
叫做分析行业的钱20名
二十名好那我们来看看这个东西有没有机会那么还是来到我们的还是来到我们的罗盘
然后呢在罗盘里头大家呢可以呢去点击商品榜单
然后呢我在商品榜单里头呢我现在就是想做鞋垫那我就在这个位置里头呢我就选择配件
然后呢我就选择一个鞋垫
然后怎么样呢
一我做商品卡我就在上面这个位置我说我就只选商品卡
明白我的意思吗
二那品牌和不是品牌还是有区别的
有些东西大家就只认品牌
所以我在这个位置里头一定是选择非知名品牌
意思就是我要把品牌的影响给它降到最低
比如说大家如果说都看品牌
那我没有收太多机会是这样的道理吧
然后这个时候大家其实呢还可以看价格
但是呢放到这儿你们可以看一下行业的前20名
然后呢你们可以看到行业的前20名
这个支付的金额是多少啊
你们可以看到没有
7天的支付金额是多少啊
7天的支付金额是
等一下
这个好像稍微等一下
没选中稍微等一下啊
然后呢
大家可以看见
大家可以看见没有
7天的营业额是多少
这好多少
25万
那平均一天
3到4万块钱
卖鞋铁一个链接一天
能做3到4万块钱
然后我们来看看前20名
大家可以看一下前20名
前20名大家看见没有
2.5万
那平均一天
你们可以去算一下
平均一天三四千走的
营业额
那我觉得这个行业
我觉得这个行业还可以
对吧
因为我去除了品牌
我去除了我单一的渠道
它一天能做三四千
其实我们想说的是一个行业
怎么样呢
不要说一天做三四千
在我的心目当中
如果说一个行业
一个产品
一天能做一千块钱左右的业额
这个行业就可以去做
因为毕竟我们未来做的不是一款产品
未来我们肯定是做了很多款产品
你们能明白我这一次吗
而且呢大家真正做电商
不要相信网上的什么天天暴富啊
天天的什么人均百万人均千万
不是的
真正做电商
我们说的真心话
你们是通过很多产品堆起来的一页额
不是一个产品让你们一页额是不是做了几十万
所以单一的行业去分析的时候
如果说平均下来
大家都有个千百块钱一天的一页额
这个链接这个行业就是可以做的
所以这个行业是有市场的
明白我的意思吧
也就是说那我可以做好多品吧
我又不是只做一个品
如果说就是这个行业好
我也可以开好几家店行不行
我开五家店
我一天的业额是不是就有五千了
所以大家千万不是说只有一个行业是不是只有1万块钱一天
不用这样子
你们就可以看看人家的这个东西
平均的这个行业里头前二十名有一千块钱一天
这个行业就是一个好行业
所以大家可以看看
你们会认为鞋店这东西也能卖
大家其实事实上可以看到
鞋店这个行业它也是有利润的
是这样的道理吧
所以呢大家可以看一下这个里头我得给大家这张图
为什么呢
因为在做这个分析的时候有几个细节点啊
哪几个细节点呢
一是先选自己的类目
二是这里头一定是选择你们渠道
三是一定选择了非知名品牌
一定选择非知名品牌啊
所以呢这个里头呢是一
二
然后呢
三
四
五
去除品牌以后
有没有销量
说到这也给大家讲一个故事
知道什么是生意吗
你们知道什么叫生意吗
生意就是挑软柿子泥
你们去做这个生意的时候
你得再想一件事
你的同行
你能不能
捏洞
就来我自己来讲吧
我二零二
二零一五年的时候
当时我是陶大的讲师
身边有朋友来找我
他说
虚主啊
他说我们准备投资一千万
准备去卖干果
他说你帮我们来操盘
给你百分之三十的干股
我们一起干
心动不心动
我想了一下二话没说不干
你们知道为什么不干吗
因为我对行业太了解了
对这个行业
这个行业就三巨头
哪三巨头呢
三只松鼠
两品铺子
白草味
他们三巨头霸占着整个市场百分之七十啊
那一千万听上去很多
但是三只松鼠一年的广告
三只松鼠一年的广告费是五个亿
还是呢我们在义乌招的是什么人
我们在义乌招的视觉和三只松鼠的视觉能比
你看三只松鼠做成这种卡通形象都非常好看
那你说推广费没它高
美工美工没得厉害
产品供应链人家做到百亿级别的企业
和你一家普通级别企业随家的供应链强
千万不要说我们自己的供应链有多强
我想了一下
在他们面前像我这种级别的
那真的就叫做小卡拉咪
意思就是这个市场我根本连碰都不用去碰
这个人家的级别都太太高了
千万不要高估自己的能力
所以我在分析这个数据的时候
是我在思考我的竞争对手到底强不强
也就是说他不强我就可以去干
明白的是吗
但是比如说大家都是品牌都是黑标
能干吗
就比如说这期这期同学没有上一期有个同学问我
他说老师我想做化妆品
我就问他我说你想做什么化妆品啊
他说我想做脸霜我想做面膜
我问了他第二句话我说你有品牌授权吗
他说没有老师是白牌
有机会没有机会
没有
就是大家上演的东西或多或少都得是个品牌
再便宜也得是个品牌
但是什么东西是有机会的呢
眼线笔是有机会的
因为眼线笔大家是不挑品牌的
是好用就行
然后什么东西是有机会的
化妆刷是有机会的
因为你们买化妆刷
你们是不看品牌
但是如果说是脸霜面膜这种东西
大家一定会认品牌
实际上的道理吧
所以这个好
那这个数据来看
其实还可以
那第二件事情看啥
看有没有利润嘛是吧
好了那看看有没有利润呢
到哪看呢
到类目挖掘里头
类目盖矿和类目挖掘里头都可以
然后呢我们在这个位置里头呢
我去大家可以看一下底下这里头它就会有一个价格带
我在这里头呢我去选择一下鞋垫好了
然后看一下哪一个价格带成交的人数多
然后呢大家可以按照这个成交人数上来看
然后呢第二个维度呢一眼看过去以后
哪个价格带成交的多呀
你们发现19块钱以上有没有成交人数啊
有没有
有然后大家可以看见0到10块钱成交的最多
然后你发现10到14块钱
10到25万
那意思就是我在选价格我在选品的时候
我是不是可以去选10到14块钱的鞋垫
可不可以
或者说我我选0到10块钱鞋垫行不行
也行
那好了那好了很多人说了那怎么判断这个东西有没有利润呢
那然后到哪里去判断呢
到类目挖掘里头去判断
然后呢我先随便大家看见没有找到鞋垫
点击详细分析
看见没有平台也给他打上了一个标识
看见没有鞋垫这个行业啥
竞争小
增长
很快而且还成交
高
其实啊平台都告诉你们了
只是你们自己看不看的
懂
你们能明白我的意思吗
好了
那比如说我们在这个位置里头呢
我们呢给大家点进去以后
我们来看一下
看看这个价格有没有机会呢
然后点击一下他
看见没有
攻击指数就这个虚空比就代表竞争
意思就是0到30块钱的协定竞争是
竞争是小的
然后呢你们还记得50到80的竞争
也还可以80到120的也可以
530到50的竞争稍微大一点
意思就是各个价格带的鞋垫其实都可以买
那好了我们看看有没有利润啊
好了那我们点开这个位置呢
你看点击0到30我可以点开这个榜单
这个时候呢就是行业里头卖的比较好的
那比如说我现在就想看一下这个款
这个款是什么呢
你们忘记9块93双
我们来看看这个款有没有有没有利润
你看毛龙鞋垫
然后怎么看呢有没有利润呢
我们在之前给大家说过你们可以装一个插件
可以去分析1688里头的整个同款的价格
对比一下1688里头同款的价格
还记得是哪个插件吗
嗯
其实是1688采购助手
装完以后大家可以点开这个位置上面上面有个剪刀
然后呢你们可以在这个位置里头呢
大家可以呢点开来看一下
然后呢看一下这个鞋垫呢
大概在多少钱
然后呢一眼看过去以后
看见没有多少钱
9毛
三双多少钱
3块
再加上2块钱的运费
5块
卖9块9
我觉得还行啊
利润最起码都是在
30%以上是这样的道理吧
所以呢那我哪怕我们就能按到这个东西算好了
意思就是你们发现按2块钱算好了
三双
你们会发现三双6块
对吧
6块再加2块钱的运费
8块9块9
也有一两块钱左右的利润
利润率基本上在20%到40%左右
那我会认为
这个东西是有利润的
但是比如说我一看1688里头东西的价格
1688里头价格对比抖音价格都差不多了
那就说明这个东西
没有太多的利润对吧
所以你们只要有你们可以看见你们只要装过这个插件
你们以截图去找一下同款
看一下别人家的这种到底有没有到底是有没有利润吗
就可以了
所以大家可以看到
这个东西是有一定的利润的
然后大家再去看看
这里头还有这个足利件不能比
这个足利件是个品牌的
然后你们可以自己去看
这种东西到底有没有利润
说着真心话
三块钱也不亏本
三块钱只是不赚钱而已
九毛加两块刚好是三块钱
是这样的道理吧
一双装
所以第二件事情判断一下
我们家的这个东西总体的价格带
竞争怎么样
所以二分析一下行业的前20名
看看行业的前20名
日均营业额
营业额能达到1000以上的行业
大家可以去碰
这种行业说明给你们留有机会了
明白我的意思吗
也就是说
但是这个有一点啊
这个的话呢得要定取这里头有两个细节啊
那么这里头有哪两个细节呢
一个细节是去除品牌
一个细节是什么呢
一个细节是定渠道
就我的这个渠道
看看日均的销量大概在多少
然后呢第三件事情呢
你们去分析一下行业的价格带
然后呢你们去看一下哪个价格带
一个是成交人数多
二哪一个价格带呢
上面那个位置有什么虚贡比啊
是不是啊
所以呢
哪一个价格带的他的整个竞争小
其实呢我们是真正来讲你们是先选品再定价格
真正懂的人其实是先定价格在
选品这个行业竞争小我就去做
这个行业明白我这一次吗
很多人说老师能看出来哪个行业竞争哪个价格在竞争小吗
当然可以看出来
刚才大家在这个地方给你们去演示的时候
我不知道你们看没看见没有
一个是平台
他已经帮你们你们点去他就会有
虚共比对吧
你看我点这个价格他就有虚共比
但是如果说你们想看的更细致
比如就拿零到十块钱来讲好了
那你们退回来吗
到类目盖矿里头
类目盖矿里头大家去选择鞋店
选择完鞋店以后
大家可以看一下
那你们可以看见没有
这个位置里头有什么东西呢
你们可以看到一眼看过去以后
你们看见没有
成交人数是有的
然后呢
动销商品数是有的
你们可以看见没有
成交人数除上动销商品数
那这个行业是多少呢
这个行业是100吗
对吧
然后呢你们可以看一下
呃0到14块钱呢
你看看成交人数是25万
这个是5000
5000乘以多少是25万
你看看这个行业是50吗
你看14到17块钱
你看看这个是10
这个是5000
这个是多少
你看看这个是20吗
你看看这个是10
这个是2500
这是多少
这个多少
你看看这是40吗
然后呢你们发现这个是25
这个是多少
谁帮我算一下25万
数据7500是多少
然后呢你们发现
那什么意思呢
意思就是我未来去找鞋垫
鞋垫不需要卖那种很贵的鞋垫
对吧
因为你们发现竞争小的就两个
你们发现0到10块钱的
10到14块钱的
成交人数又多
竞争又小
意思就是我不用去找那种很好的鞋垫
大家都喜欢9块9
那我去挑的鞋垫也就是1块钱一双
10块钱三双10块钱四双
这种鞋垫
大家就很喜欢
也就是说根据价格带去选品
不是根据选品
再有价格带
选完品再有价格带你们会有点痛苦
但是根据价格带再去选品
你们的方向就有了
大家喜欢便宜货
我找的也都是便宜货
对吧
所以呢
你们一眼看过去以后这个思路是不是就清晰了呀
分析价格带的时候分析的是哪些东西呢
哪个价格带成交的人数多
哪个价格带成交的金额
这竞争会更小
竞争小是用虚贡比
虚贡比越高
然后竞争越小
然后呢
再去根据价格带的榜单
商品
然后呢
对比1688
1688的商品
然后呢
看一下利润率
利润率得达到多少呢
利润率呢
最起码是20%到50%
意思就是
30%以上的利润率
这个品就可以去推
为什么
你们不要认为真实的利润率能达到30%啊
这里还涉及到广告费呢
看上去有50%
可能50%里头还有一部分是被广告给均摊了
明白我这一次吗
所以呢
到这块为止
我就知道一个行业到底能做还是不能做了
大家拍下照片
第一个维度是基础维度分析
第二个维度是整个行业进阶分析
进阶分析里头在分析什么呢
分析这个行业哪个渠道卖货的
第二个
大家在这个渠道里头别人家能卖多少
利润卖到什么样的价格
利润还有没有
如果说有利润价格也还可以
那就说明这个行业可以做
那比如说我就定下来了
我定下来了我们就准备去做什么了呢
我们定下来了我就准备做鞋垫
但是鞋垫可能这里头也有很多的款式
比如说我们自己是做笔袋文具的
那笔袋不是只有一个款
笔袋也有很多的款是这样的道理吧
所以呢行业定下来了
第二件事情是什么呢
第二件事情那就是开始去找
卖什么样的款式
但是有一点大家再去看
我们前面教大家做的所有动作
没有一句话是
我觉得所有东西都是看数据
然后呢如果说大家未来去操作的时候会发现自己没有数据
为啥呢
因为抖音啊只能看到两个数据
一个就是你们上传了哪个商品
就能看哪个页目的数据
二是这个商品上架以后要破零
不管谁破零只要破零就有数据
所以呢第一个阶段基础课听完以后
你们应该做的事情是
店铺当中把你们想做的行业都给它上架
而且去破零
否则没有数据
好
那这个动作做完以后呢
那么我们就进入到了整个第二个动作
第二个动作里头呢
我们开始呢给大家呢
去讲讲叫做数据化选品
好
那么说句话选品的话呢
我刚才呢给大家呢去讲了几个点
我说选品有三种方式
说错了有四种方式
那么哪四种方式呢
一平台需要的品就放在那叫做商机商品
这个最最最最最最最最最最建议
就是平台就是要这些品
二是什么品呢
二是更款
然后呢
三是根据行业的热门属性
来这些选款
然后呢
四是报款搬运
好
那么我们来讲这个之前呢
我们稍微来休息一下
休息15分钟到20分钟
回来呢继续来稍微休息一下
回来继续
好
谢谢观看
感谢观看
一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万一千万
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
请不吝点赞 订阅 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
请不吝点赞 订阅 订阅 订阅 订阅 订阅 订阅 订阅 订阅 订阅 订阅 订阅 订阅 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
订阅 订阅 订阅 订阅 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
根本没有谱章的样子
没有谱章的样子
我们没有谱章的样子
没有谱章的影响
没谱章的影响
您好 您来一下
您好 您都来一下
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
请不吝点赞 订阅 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点栏目
请不吝点赞 订阅 订阅 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点栏目
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点栏目
打赏支持明镜与点栏目
全网的品呢他都帮你们呢去整理一下
然后呢大家呢点击到这个位置里头以后
大家可以呢来看一下
就大家可以看到这个位置里头点进来以后呢
上面会有很多很多的品
然后呢也就有什么全网热卖
也就有什么印记
有什么热度高
大家看见没有上面这个位置才会有很多的推荐理由
好了
然后呢大家可以看到这里的话呢还有什么叫做
呃什么叫做跟潜力报品
好了那我们来看一下啊
首先呢第一个维度里头呢
第一个维度里头呢上面有个推荐理由
上面有什么全网热卖
上面有这些什么呃印记报款
上面有什么热度高
上面有什么中小商家一报
我想问的是这些品里头该怎么去选
第一个选品的位置
位置是在商机中心
反正大家呢也都不懂你们猜嘛
我们大家可以呢
大家可以来猜一下
就是这个里头
你们觉得推荐理由里头一般选哪一个
你看推荐理由里头一般选哪一个
全网热卖
我们来简单的解答一下
全网热卖什么意思呢
全网热卖说的更加直白一点
你们可以看见市场热度高
抖音缺货
而且的话呢
就是卖的比较好的
然后呢
印记爆发是什么意思呢
你们可以看见当前季节或者未来两个月内卖的好的
然后呢热度高是什么呢
消费者主动搜索
而且呢你发现视频热度比较高的
然后呢成长增速快是什么呢
成长增速快的话呢
就是增长快的
平台缺货呢
平台缺货就是平台缺货
中小卖家一爆单的话呢
就是投广告容易出单的
那我想问问这里头有这么几个
你们觉得推荐里流里头
你们觉得应选哪一个
应该选哪一个
然后呢首先第一个
那个全网络售卖这个东西要不要选
要不要选
不要
你们选全网络售卖谁不知道选全网络售卖
大家都照着全网络售卖去选
那我说这句话
这个东西不一定抢得过别人的
热卖代表已经卖得很好了
那我说这句话你们真正帽也是热卖
但是你们去推真正帽有机会吗
没有
所以呢好多人说老师这头选哪一个
然后呢印记爆发我们会选
为什么呢
因为他说的是下未来两个月里头
他的增长趋势会比较快的
因为大家是中小卖家
你们要去卖一些大盘能够增长的
大盘能够增长的东西
能带着你们去成长
这种东西会更好做
然后呢第二个热度高是可以的
搜索大家搜索的多
这个是可以的
然后呢三增速快是可以的
四平台缺货
如果说你们能找到这个货
他绝对挣钱
五中小商家一报
也就是说在我们的理念里头
除去第一个全网热卖之外
其他的这几个
其实大家都可以去选择
很多人说老大你给我们一个建议吧
那我们一般建议的话呢
那个印记
然后呢热度高
然后呢中小商家
一报
反正这个是我们三个
选的最多的三个
维度所以呢
推荐理由里头
我们一般呢会这样建议大家去选
然后呢推荐理由里头的话呢印记
然后呢热度高
热度高的意思是搜索的人数多
那说明大家有这个其实代表搜索的人数多
然后呢
嗯你们会发现
这里头有一个品啊
叫做平台缺货
大概率啊
平台都缺货了
大概率你们也缺货
但是如果说大家真的能找到
那这种品也真的挣钱
这是大概率上这种是这样子的
然后呢
还有的话呢
增速快
反正这三个都还可以
反正呢
我们比较鼓励大家呢
印记
就是我们比较鼓励大家呢
印记的品
大家可以去
去做一做
我们鼓励大家的呢
热度高的品
鼓励大家呢
可以去做一做
然后呢
增长快的品也可以
但是这两个的话呢
是我比较鼓励大家呢
可以去做一下
好
那么第2个
大家可以看一下
这个位置里头呢
上面还有一些扶持
那我想问的是
选择哪些扶持
你们觉得这种品质好做
你看这里头有权益
有扶持
扶持选一些什么样的扶持啊
大家就只看到有人给我给钱就好是吗
目标比较简单明确
谁给我钱
当然呢
其实呢
但也没错
但是呢
这个里头我们一般会
我们一般会怎么去选呢
那么首先呢
给大家来讲讲它是啥意思啊
那个啥意思呢
一搜索扶持
那个搜索不是什么意思呢
在搜索页面里头
会给大家2000次左右的曝光
2到3000次曝光
新品上新是给你们14天到28天的一个扶持
猜你喜欢
这个里头先等一下我得给大家
给大家先去讲这么大一个概念
我先把这个放在这给大家去讲一个什么概念呢
然后呢什么是搜索呢
搜索就是在这个里头搜索完垃圾袋以后
然后呢他会在这个界面里头给你们两到三千次出现在客户面前的机会
这就是搜索扶持
推荐扶持
猜你喜欢热卖权是什么意思呢
他指的是在首页的这个位置里头
大家呢平台会给你们会给你们一些机会
在首页的这个位置里头呢
他会给你们差不多三千次左右的曝光
然后呢150块钱的流量红包
这就是流量红包
广告扶持就是广告能推得动
返佣就是佣金会返给大家
降佣就是佣金会比较低
很多人说老师
选哪一个
你们就选哪一个呀
知道了
第一搜索扶持是要的
因为搜索扶持它是实实在在的流量很精准
二上心扶持是可以的
上心扶持说明这是新品
而且有14天的报告
猜冷起这个一般不要
为什么
它出现在猜你喜欢里头猜你喜欢里头这个流量其实并没有想象当中那么
精准明白我的意思吗
然后呢大家可以看见
除了这地方以外还有那个
热卖权益啊什么猜你喜欢不要
但凡是猜你喜欢的热卖权益
都不要
然后呢150块钱的流量包讲150块钱
这是送给我的那也可以
反正都是送给我的广告券
然后呢广告容易跑得动的也可以
就是广告呢会优先的让他给流量
这是可以的
反正呢我们一般在推荐扶持里头呢
鼓励大家呢选几大类的扶持的品
那么所以呢权益选择
一般选择什么呢
选择有搜索扶持的
然后呢第二有什么呢
有流量券送的
平台给我给钱去推品
这么好的事情跟简的一样
然后呢有上心扶持
最主要就是这三个
这个就是我们自己
上心扶持
也就是说这三个是我们主要去选择的
好
所以呢我们一般呢在这个位置里头呢
选择他这里头
然后呢底下呢你们要的扶持呢
你们就可以给他勾选一下
你看勾选上
这是可以一起勾选的
你看有上星扶持
然后呢有150块钱流量红包
然后呢你们可以看到有什么草品扶持
然后呢有广告扶持
好了我放到这个位置里头
那行那到这个位置里头以后呢
你看这里头它就会有很多的品
那这个品行不行呢
大家呢点开这个位置
大家呢可以看到这头有很多的数据
嗯问问大家你们觉得这个品行还是不行
大家觉得这个品行还是不行
怎么判断这个品行还是不行
你看
你看这个品就放在这了
怎么判断这个品行还是不行啊
然后呢我们一般的通过几个维度来看
第一个维度的话呢看一下时间
也就是说你们可以看一下它的时间是多长时间呢
12月28号
然后呢现在才几号
1月7号
一看发布时间超过两个月以上的品
如果说你们一看到这以后
一个月的时间它都已经在热卖了
那我说这真实话
可能留给你们的机会不多了
为什么说留给你们的机会不多了呢
说明这个品已经卖了很久了
所有的产品都是有生命
周期的
然后呢第二个维度呢
看什么东西呢
看能不能卖货
看看卖货这个东西
他有没有在在卖
很多人说老师那那怎么判断呢
然后大家可以看一下他这个里头每天的成交额
就是你们可以看一下这个位置里头他每天的成交额
不用多
在全网
如果说这个品每天的成交额能到能做到一万块钱以上
所以不要说一万块钱五千块钱以上
那我就认为这个品是还可以的
明白我这意思吗
然后呢
第三个刚才有同学说虚共比对
虚共比什么意思呢
很多人说老师其实不太理解这里头0.8是什么意思
包括有的时候这个地方有10是什么意思
10是什么意思呢
10的意思就是10个商家抢一个客户
这就是10的意思
0.8是什么意思呢
0.8的意思就是一个商家抢0.87个客户
明白我的意思吗
比如说说的更加直白一点
这一个商家抢8.7个客户
你们就可以这么认为
每个商家就等于说
就这么说吧
就等于说
数值越高就代表竞争越小
数值越小就证明这个竞争是越惨烈的
如果说是0.1是什么意思
0.1就是10个商家去抢
一个客户
你们能明白我的意思吗
0.87就是0.87的话呢
其实就是说的更加直白一点
就是就是一个商家去抢了
0.87个客户
很多人说这个多少会合适
不要看三十天
因为呢有些品你们点进去以后
大家就看三十天
真的维京都已经到淡季了
维京都竞争已经激烈了
但是你看有些品点进去以后
三十天这个数据是不是看上去还挺高的呀
但是呢你们可以去点一下七天
然后呢你就点击一下近一天
七天的虚共比能达到二以上
近一天的虚共比能达到0.5以上的品
我们就认为这个品还有机会
而且大家可以在这个位置里头去简单的看一下他们的趋势
然后呢如果说你们在这个趋势里头一眼看过去以后
成交金额的趋势一路在都在涨
那就说明这个品就是有机会的
所以呢第一个维度呢
你们发现所以呢这个里头呢叫做商机商品的数据分析
商机商品里头的数据分析呢几个维度
那么哪几个维度呢
第一个维度发布时间
建议大家呢整个发布时间呢控制在两个月内的
不要两个月以上的品给你们留机会不多了
你们去想两个月以上的品你们自己再推一下的一个月
一个品三个月三个月一个品基本上就
就市场就已经差不多了
所以呢第一个然后呢第二个维度呢
分析第二个维度呢分析啥
刚才说的第二个维度分析啥
第二个维度分析啥
分析交易额
然后呢你发现日均交易额在多少以上呢
在5000以上这个品就可以
然后呢第三个维度分析
第三个维度的话呢
去分析趋势
总体的趋势呢比较稳定
或者呢是上升
上升
第四个维度的话呢
去分析虚共比
虚共比
虚共比里头呢分析了几个
一
30天的虚共比
5以上
虚共比的话呢
5以上的
然后呢
七天的虚共比呢
虚共比呢
2以上
然后呢
一天的虚共比的话呢
0.5以上
好了
这种品呢
大家可以呢尝试去做
好了
这第一个维度
第一个维度里头的话呢
是单纯的商品的
交易数据
这个的话呢
你们会见我们把这些统称为什么呢
叫做交易数据
因为那很多人说老师第二个东西要分析什么呢
第二个分析利润呢
这个东西有没有利润
所以呢大家点击到这个位置里头来
你们往底下来看
看见没有
在底下的这个位置里头
上面有一个叫动销价格带
有看见吗
很多人说老师什么叫动销价格带
动销就是有销量的意思
更易动销什么意思
就是好卖的价格带
所以呢
价格带是多少
76%
然后呢
那我想看看这东西有没有利润
你们可以点开这个位置
然后呢
点开这个品的位置
两种方法
一种的话呢
你们装够插件
很多人说老师我没装够插件行不行呢
没关系
你们可以截图
截图完了以后呢
你们可以到1688的界面里头
大家可以直接去1688的界面
1688的界面里头上面这个地方是不是有一个以图搜货呀
你们可以点击粘贴到这个位置里头
然后呢你们去搜索看看这个品多少钱
然后呢我一眼看过去以后看人家销量高的这种商品
然后呢他卖多少钱
然后呢你们发现1411块921
也就是说他卖3321
那就说明这个品还是有
这个品是不是有利润的呀
也就是说我先不用对比11的这个
你们看下这些销量高的这些22 20
那我一眼看过去以后我会发现那这些品都还是有利润的
但如果说有一个品他没销量意义就不大了
明白我的意思吗
好了所以呢那从这个角度来看
那说明这个品他也还有利润
那除去利润之外我还要看什么东西呢
再去看一下他是哪个渠道带的货
所以呢你们在底下这个位置里头
你们看见底下这个位置里头
这个品主要是在哪来卖呀
商品卡来卖
而且的话呢自然流量为主
然后呢你们可以看见石锅也能卖
但是主要是商品卡
再看一下人群
人群的话呢
大家可以看一下什么
核心的人群是自身中产精致妈妈
那这说明这个人群都还是比较优质的
是这样的道理吧
所以呢第二件事情
第二件事情叫做什么呢
第二件事情的话
第一个数据呢叫商品的
第一个的话呢叫做商品数据
交易数据分析
第二个方向的话呢
叫什么分析呢
叫做产品数据分析
数据还有呢
人群分析
那么第一个维度里头呢
去分析一下它的动销价格带
价格带
然后呢
来对比1688的价格
看一下商品有没有30%以上的利润空间
利润空间
然后呢
第二件事情来干嘛呢
第二件事情的话呢
看一下整体的这种渠道和载体
大家都是做商品卡的
看看商品卡能不能卖户
看一下它是通过哪些渠道呢
把这货给卖掉的
第三件事情的话呢
看一下人群
人群里头就只有一个点
不做老年人的生意
除非说等大家老了
否则呢
现在这个阶段的老年人的生意
很多人特别喜欢做老年人的生意
说着真心话
老年人的生意啊
除了保健品
退货率比较低的这种
剩下的东西
售后问题是比较多的
明白我的意思吗
所以呢
一般呢
不介意
选择老年人的产品
他们不是没有钱
所以呢
这个是我们来讲到的
当我去分析到了一个好的产品之后
那么我们接下来去做的事情是什么呢
你们看见没有
我在这个位置以后呢
我对所有的商品呢
进行了两个维度的分析
哪两个维度的分析呢
第一个维度的分析的话呢
就是这个东西能不能卖
第二个维度的话呢
分析呢
这个东西呢
它有没有利润
好
那很多人说老师我做完了这个东西分析
那做完这个东西分析以后
好多人说老师接下来开始该干嘛
接下来两件事
一件事情呢
就是我同款该怎么去找
对吧
找同款这件事情
大家刚才给大家演示了
找同款这件事情无非就是两个
一个的话呢
要么你们的这个界面里头
你们有去装过
大家可以看到没有
你们有去装过1688采购助手
你们可以直接的去以图
你们可以直接的以图去搜货
这是可以的
第二个的话呢
你们可以直接截图
截完图以后到1688的锁页里头
是不是有一个以图搜货呀
但是呢
如果说大家想获得扶持
不能说光发布
想获得扶持该怎么办呢
大家往我们底下的这个界面里头
大家可以来看
你们可以看到没有
这个位置里头它有两个按钮
哪两个按钮呢
一个按钮叫做
关联商品
意思就是先发布起来
然后到这个位置里头来
把跟自己店铺里头的商品来进行
关联
这个时候才能拿到扶持
二
要么一不做二不休
你们直接在这个位置里头呢
你们可以看见没有
我就直接的在这个界面里头
大家看见没有
我可以直接发布商品啊
对
然后呢
我就在这个位置里头呢
我就直接发布相似商品
也是可以的
两种方法
两种方法都可以
但是很多人说老师啊
那个我们家现在没有图该怎么办呢
我想快速的去发布
其实呢
这个时候呢
我们会之前给大家去讲基础课程的时候
给大家曾经讲过一个工具
我不知道大家有没有印象
之前给大家讲过一个什么工具呢
大家呢可以到服务市场
服务市场里头呢
我之前讲了批量发布商品里头有一个工具
叫小风上货
对吧
然后呢其实小风上货里头有一个功能
是可以直接通过商机中心的品
它可以一键发布
举个例子啊给大家来看
你们可以看到没有
这个位置里头他们会有个选品中心
然后呢在这个选品中心里头
大家点进去以后
你们看见没有
上面这个是不是有个叫做商机选品中心啊
有看见吗
你们就直接点击这个地方
就是它也可以到这来
然后呢你们到这个里头来以后呢
你们可以看到
然后比如说我看到这个款
我可以直接选中
然后呢点击立即扑货
也就是说它也会帮你去去找通话
所以呢这里头呢需要呢有两个技能啊
有哪两个技能呢
第一个技能的话呢就是找同款
商品里头的话呢大家如果说要去找同款
反正呢给大家推荐了三个工具哪三个工具呢
第一个的话呢是一个插件1688采购助手
在360637里头可以直接安装
那么第二个维度的插件第二个插件是什么插件呢
第二个插件的话呢就是大家呢以图搜货
以图搜货
第三个插件的话呢是服务市场里头有小峰工具
小峰出货工具
然后呢到这
那么发布了以后不够啊
发布了以后呢你们想获得扶持一定得做一个动作
一定得做一个什么动作呢
就是你们想获得扶持
扶持一定要关联商品
不关联商品获得不了扶持
一定得到这里头呢来关联商品
或者你们就直接从发布的时候呢
你们就直接从这个地方呢点击发布商品
好
讲到这儿呢
第一个选品的方式呢
我们就算是给大家讲完了
第一个选品方式的话呢
其实主要是在讲我们的整个商机中心的选品
商机中心的选品里头呢
讲了几件事情
一件事情是推荐理由
还有权益该怎么去选择
第二件事情呢
商品的数据该怎么去看
那么第三件事情的话呢
是选完的这些款到哪里去找
第四个的话呢
是怎么获得关联的扶持
而且再次强调
这个位置里头的品是我最建议大家去选的
为什么
因为平台把自己想要的品都已经告诉你们
它是明确的告诉你
现在平台就是要机械品
所以你们可以看到
这些品大家只要上传
平台就会给你们
平台就会给你们扶持
好
那么除去这个地方以外
那很多老师还有什么样的方法可以去选的
这个是最最最简单
就是中小卖家在选品的时候
不用到处去漫天去选品
这个位置里头的产品是第一步里头大家可以去筛选的
好了那第二件事情该到哪去选品呢
那第二件事情那就是跟款咯
别人家卖的好我也卖是这样的道理吧
所以呢第二个维度呢给大家呢来讲讲我们的整个跟款
所以呢我们呢来讲讲呢我们的整个第二种选品的方法叫做跟款
那么商品跟款这个板块呢嗯讲几个维度呢从几个维度来讲呢呃第一个维度叫做基础的基础的跟款逻辑
然后呢第二件事大家都说要去跟款那第二件事情就是我要跟着这些款到哪里去找我到哪里去找到别人家卖的比较好的位置所以呢
产品的查找
那么找到以后呢第三件事情
我怎么去看这个竞争对手这个商品的数据对吧所以呢叫做竞品的数据分析
好了我们呢从三个位置去讲跟款
到哪里去做
好那第一个位置第一个位置叫做跟款的基本逻辑
我先不讲其他我先问问你们啊比如说现在你们开了
比如说啊现在你们开了一家超市
然后呢超市里头呢有一款产品卖爆了这款产品差不多一天能出一千单卖爆了
我想问的是你们会不会把自己的供应商给换掉
比如说这个是一直都是这个时候你们一直在帮你们供货的
你会不会把这供货的人给换掉
但凡说会的人一定没有做过生意
按理来讲一般你们不会轻易把这供应商换掉
为什么不会轻易换掉呢
因为你不知道换成其他人以后他有没有货
二你也不知道换成其他人以后他的品质怎么样
所以大概率上来讲你不会换掉他
是这样的道理吧
另外一句话送给你们
就是从平台的角度也是这样子的
如果说一个品卖的特别特别特别特别特别特别好
平台凭什么要把他的流量给你们
你们最起码得给给平台一个理由
比如说你跟平台说我愿意给你钱也行
要么你跟平台说我卖的比他低也行
对吧
也就是你得给平台一个理由
但是大概率上来讲
平台你要把别人的流量抢过来
你是要花出比较大的这种代价的
所以很多人说老师报款我去跟
所以大家会发现很多人跟报款以后啊
你们就是传说中的炮灰
为什么这么样去找呢
别人卖的好
然后剩下的那些库存消化不掉
全都在谁人的手里头呢
都在你们这群小白手里头
我们身边有个朋友就专门做这个事情
干嘛呢
别人看这个品牌的差不多了
他一次性把库存全收过来
然后在大全网搜的社群里头去发
我有某某某报款的供应链
大家要不要低价
但是必须得拿一千个
人们一看这个价格也很便宜
一千个就一千个吧
一拿拿回家发现以后
大盘开始
下跌了
因为你不知道这个生命周期在哪里
是这样的道理吧
所以呢
很多人说老师啥意思呢
我们去判断一个款能不能跟的时候
我们是这么样来判断的
那么我们怎么判断呢
我们是通过两个维度来判断一个款
能不能跟
哪两个维度呢
第一个是我会有一个叫做横着的
轴线去分析
一个呢
叫送着的轴
横着轴是
什么维度呢
横着的轴的话呢
叫销量
因为大家跟款前提就是他得卖的好我才去跟嘛
对吧
所以呢
销量这个东西呢我会是会关注的
那么第二个维度是什么维度呢
第二个维度的话那是种着轴的这个维度
那么这个维度叫
这个维度叫什么呢
这个维度呢叫增幅
它的增长速度
所以呢
商品会经历四个阶段
哪四个阶段呢
第一个阶段呢
一个商品的增长速度很快
但是呢
销量不高
所以呢
我们一般把这个阶段的品
我们一般把它称作为什么品呢
叫做潜力品
就是增长快
但是呢
销量不高
然后呢
第二个阶段的品是什么呢
第二个阶段的话呢
增长还是很快
增长快
而且呢
销量也不低
销量也高
这个瓶我们把它称作为什么瓶呢
这个瓶的话呢
我们把它称作为爆发瓶
第三个瓶的话呢
销量高
但是整个大盘整个它的销量已经不增长了
所以呢
第三个的话呢
叫做销量高
但是不增长
这个瓶的话呢
我们把它称作为
热卖瓶
然后呢
第四个的话呢
是销量不高
而且呢
也不增长
这个品的话呢
我们就把它称作为衰退品
或者是把它称作为受购品
衰退品
所以呢
我们一般在分析一款产品的时候呢
我们是会从四个板块
我们是会从四个板块来分析一款产品
然后呢
我来问一下大家
你们觉得这四个阶段里从哪个阶段的品是可以跟的
对了
你们觉得哪个阶段品
哪个阶段可以跟呢
一阶段能跟吗
不可以
一阶段得关注
为什么
因为它有可能是刷单刷出来的
有可能他投了一千块钱广告
出了十单
但是你看上去它的销量增长
但是实际上它是
血亏
这个阶段它还亏着
可能是可能到下一个阶段它就不投意了
有这种可能性吧
所以呢
你们发现这个阶段的品
它只是在展示它的潜力
所以呢
重点关注
看看
有没有机会
明白我的意思吗
然后呢
第二个阶段称作为
这个阶段
跟不跟
赶紧动手
再不动手
跟不上了
这个品就要
卖爆了
然后呢
第三个阶段
人家卖得很好
大盘已经不增长
这个阶段的品呢
这个阶段的品
你们得
观望一下
看看还有没有机会
很多人说老师观望啥
观望一下这款商品有没有
观望一下这款商品有没有利润呢
观望一下这款商品
评分怎么样啊
卖的商家多不多呀
然后呢
大盘都不长的这种品
我们一般呢
把这种品呢
称作为
那这种品大家就赶紧去
这种品大家就赶紧去放弃
在讲到这儿的时候呢
我们经常会把这四个阶段呢
用一个轴来表达出来
然后呢
它分别是你看
这是
这是我刚才去讲的讲到的一
这是二
这是三
这是四
如果说从一个数轴上来一看
它是一个什么样的情况呢
然后所有的产品呢
它都是有生命周期的
所有的产品都是有
所以呢
你发现没有
这个
这个阶
这个阶段呢
就是一阶段
然后呢
这个阶段呢
就是二阶段
就是三阶段
三阶段的前期还有点机会
这个阶段呢
就是四阶段
意思就是啊
我们其实真正能有机会的是什么
二和三阶段的前期
我还有点机会
其实三阶段的后期就没我啥事情了
所以呢
我们一般把这个阶段称作为
就是你们看见现在看见的
你们现在看见的这个阶段呢
我们就把它称作为潜力阶段
然后呢
这个阶段的话呢
称作为爆发阶段
上面的这个阶段呢
我们就称作为热卖阶段
这个阶段其实就称作为什么阶段吧
衰退阶段
但是我们其实就是爆发阶段的这个品是有机会的
就是拍张照片
意思就是我们准备去跟他的这个款
我们在跟他的这个款的前提
我先分析他这个款到了哪一个阶段
明白我的意思吗
为啥刚才我不鼓励大家去选这种发布已经二十两三个月的
发布已经两三个月的品
那就说明这个品已经卖了好久好久了
那就说明如果说这个品还有利润我可以试试
如果说这个品都没有利润了
其实留给我的机会也就
留给我的机会也就不多了
是这样的大脸吧
所以呢
我们自己在选品在跟款的时候
不是盲目的说有款就跟
是在跟款之前
我会去分析一下这个款
我会去分析一下这款总体的一个
总体的一个趋势是什么样的趋势
大家能理解我的意思吗
不要盲目的去跟别人家在做我也就去做
其实别人家卖的好
你们不见得卖的好
所以呢
这一个维度里头呢
我们会说我们把品会分成几个阶段
哪几个阶段呢
潜力阶段
阶段呢
这个的话呢
大家需要去做的事情是关注
第二个阶段的话呢
你们发现爆发阶段
这个阶段的话呢
赶紧动手
然后呢
热卖阶段呢
观望一下
还看看还有没有机会
好了
那问题来了
什么问题来了
那这个方向知道了
那问题来了
就是这些好卖的品到哪里去抖音好卖的品到哪里去找
这第一个问题
第二个问题是怎么去看这些数据
是这样的道理吧
所以呢
我们呢
来讲讲我们的整个第三个叫
净品的查找
那么给大家呢
去讲三个位置
是我们去找抖音好卖款的位置
第一个小伙伴们干嘛呢
第一个小伙伴们啥都没有
为什么说小伙伴们啥都没有呢
你们发现店也没有开
但是我现在要上一些品
想初步的去看一些好卖的品
是这样的道理吧
然后呢
到哪里可以看到这些品呢
来到你们的整个抖音
然后呢
抖音里头
大家会发现这个地方是不是有一个啊
这地方是不是有一个啊
什么东西啊
电商带货 你们电商带货呢
点进去
电商带货点进去以后呢
大家看见没有这里是不是有一个啊
选品
广场啊
然后呢
你们点击选品广场
然后在选品广场里头
大家想去搜
比如说你们想去搜什么东西呢
你们想去搜鞋垫
大家就去搜一下
鞋垫
然后你们看见没有
上面这个位置里头就有鞋垫绑单
然后呢你们看见没有
这个位置里头它就会有各种各样的这种鞋垫绑单
什么加热鞋垫了
冬季鞋垫了
软弹鞋垫了
柔软鞋垫
最主要的是看见没有
这里头有个叫做趋势绑
什么是趋势绑
趋势绑就是最近上升速度都比较快
你们看见没有
最近上升速度都比较快的一些绑单
有看见吗
最主要就是没有门槛
大家只要电开起来
只要把这个抖音号跟店铺绑定过
大家都可以到这个选品广场这个位置里头来
然后呢
你们可以在这个位置里头
你们可以看到各种类型的这种鞋垫
而且那你可以在这里头看见他们家的月小量
所以呢
最简单的位置是在哪呢
然后最简单的位置呢
其实就是在你们的整个抖音号
然后呢
上面有一个叫做电商带货
上面会有一个叫选品广场
然后呢
这个位置里头呢
你们输入产品词
然后呢
输入产品词以后呢
它可以有各种各样的属性
下面呢
会有这种趋势榜
趋势榜就是增长速度比较快的
所以呢
第一个
也就是说
不需要你们后台有数据
想要看好卖的品
这个里头的品都是卖的比较
好的
看见没有啊
刚才大家看见了吗
你看见没有
这个位置里头都是卖的
大家可以看见没有
这个位置里头都是卖的比较
好的品
大家理解我的意思了吗
好
很多人说老师其他拖鞋
拖鞋 比如说我想做拖鞋可以看到款吗
可以啊
大家在这个位置里头你们就直接去
大家可以看到没有
你看底下的这个位置里头什么
热卖
然后呢
搜索搜索趋势
你们可以自己去选择上面的这种各种各样的这种
榜单
能看见吗
对吧
是不是有
所以呢
到这
比如我刚才说的很多人老师我想看拖鞋
那你们就在这里头搜索一个棉拖鞋
然后呢大家呢去点击一下搜索
搜索完以后你看见没有
家后的情侣款的儿童款的你们自己去点击
然后呢上面这个位置里头你们可以按照那个销量来排序
就是卖的比较好的一些免托鞋
你看见没有越销多少越销多少越销多少
大家可以自己在这个位置里头
大家可以自己去搜
大家可以自己去看
他呢有各种各样的这种榜单
好
这个是基础的
但是呢
进阶的是什么呢
进阶的
那我就是要有更多数据
所以呢
进阶的在哪呢
在小店后台里头呢
有个罗盘
罗盘里头呢
他会有个市场
市场里头呢
他会有一个叫做商品榜单
然后大家呢可以直接去你们的整个罗盘
罗盘里头呢
他会有一个市场
市场里头呢
大家看见没有
这里是不是有一个商品
然后呢我在商品榜单里头我是做商品卡的
我就只选商品卡
那我现在想看鞋垫
我在这个位置头看鞋垫
但是选品的时候要不要选第一页的品
要不要选第一页的品
不要
为什么不要
这呢
倒不是说品牌品牌你们倒是可以选择非知名品牌
不要选第一页的原因就是所有人都看着第一页
第一页的品一定都已经卖烂了
所以你们知道吗
我们有的时候并不希望自己冲到榜单的第一页去
第一页就是有一堆人盯着
天天都有人想把你从上面盖下来
他觉得他只要价格低
他就想把你给盖下来
所以我们一般喜欢找第几页呢
最少找三页
但是事实上最起码你们可以找个五页
大家可以在这个位置里头
你们可以去找第五页
第五页卖的也不错
二大家看见没有
这里头是不是有很多的款
上升速度很快
看见没有
上升速度
百分之五十九名
上升了五十九名
上升了二十四名
上升了三十几名
所以我们有的时候找款啊
我们不是去找一天出好几万单
一天有个一百单的款
你们去做
利润又好
还能挣钱
不是去找一天出好几万单
好几万单是没错
那是人家的单
跟你没关系
而且谁都电梯真的好几万单
别人抢这种流量方法很简单
价格卖的低
但是你们有这么低吗
低的价格吗
你们的供应链有这么强吗
你们没有
所以这是第一个维度
第二个维度的话
大家在这个位置里头去看一下转化率
转化率是不是在5%以上
如果说转化率能在5%以上
那就说明这个款还行
明白我的意思吗
所以你们可以在这个位置头
在这个位置头你们可以去看一下它的转化率怎么样
好了
然后呢
如果说转化率还可以
那我可以尝试一下
然后呢
第三个涉及到要考虑到那个投广告
你们可以算一些UV价值
什么是UV价值呢
简单的用它的营业额除上它的
就用它的营业额
除上它的点击次数
算一下
比如说像这个品能不能跟到
2.5万的支付金额
2.5万的点击次数
那平均的单价是多少
一个访客的成本是多少
就是平均带来一个访客成本是多少
平均带来一个访客成本是多少
你看
营业额是2块5
你们发现
2.5万次点击
就是一个客户带来的价值差不多就是
1块钱左右
对吧
但是呢
有些品呢
你看见没有
7500元
然后呢带来2.5
那很多人就是我的客户带来的价值会更高
明白我的意思没有啊
然后你再去看
像有些你看1万块钱2.5万
那等于这个价值会更低
我希望大家选的品是客户能带给你们价值更高的品
我们把它称作为优位价值
优位价值又被称作为仿客价值
所以呢
第二个位置里头是到罗盘的商品榜单
一定要选渠道啊
一定要选渠道
然后呢
这里头讲了几个细节
第一个细节呢
页面上来讲
我不鼓励大家去做第一页的
我建议大家去选的是五到十页的品
我建议大家选的品是在增长快的品
我建议大家选的品是转化率
最低的转化率是5%以上
当然越高越好
我建议大家选的品是UV价值高的品
UV价值高是什么呢
用营业额除上点击数
点击数
UV价值高就意味着你们未来投广告同样带来同样的人
他可以给你创造更高的业绩
明白我的意思吗
所以呢
这几个维度是基础的
大家可以去选品的
所以呢
这第二个维度
去到哪去找这行业里头卖的好的一些品
那么第三个维度是
那呢
如果说这家店做的好
那比做品做的好更牛
店做的好说明他们家不是一个品
说明他们家是总体的品都好
是这样的道理吧
所以呢
第三个维度到哪里呢
到罗盘
上面有一个市场
下面呢
会有一个叫做
店铺榜单
这个比前面更牛
所以大家可以到这个位置里头
然后大家看见没有
这里头会有个叫做店铺榜单
然后呢
你就专门找卖鞋电的
大家要做鞋电
那么你们在这个位置里头呢
大家就专门去找鞋电
然后呢
大家在这个位置里头呢
专门去找鞋电
一定要去除品牌
非知名品牌
那么你们看见没有
这些就是做鞋电做的比较好的
那么他既然整个店都做的好
那说明他们家的选品能力绝对不是说一款品
品运气准的好
说明他们家有系统的这种选品理念
这样的道理吧
所以呢
你们可以在这里头
其实大家可以查看详情
查看详情里头呢
点进去以后你们就可以看到他们家有哪些品
然后呢
你们就可以看到他们家的这些品呢
嗯
支付的金额
是多少的金额
而且你们可以看到
他能通过哪个渠道卖掉的
那他主要是通过视频去卖的
那等于说我是做商品卡
我就选择商品卡做核视频多的嘛
是这样的道理吧
所以呢
你们点到这个位置里头来
然后呢
你们可以在下面这个位置里头
去当中的选择商品卡
好了
那这个位置里头选择什么样的商家呢
这个位置里头选择什么样的商家呢
点击率高 转化率都高的是最理想的
二 转化率高的
然后呢
三 不用去选订单数
是不是你们可以看一下
这是七天的数据
是不是好几千单
日均的订单数有个
是不是整个店铺
整个店铺里头日均的订单数能达到一千单以上
我都认为这家店做的还
可以,然后呢,你们可以看到这个位置里头,就是你们可以看到他们所有的这些转化率
所以呢,第三个位置里头,选择的是什么呢?
一个是还是要选择渠道啊,渠道和飞品牌是一定要选的
飞品牌,然后呢,到这个页面里头呢,你们可以去选择店铺的整个日均
销量
然后呢,一千单以上
以上,然后呢,转化率,点击率高
然后呢,转化率高
绿高的
然后呢,产品,如果说产品少,还有一些效果好的,那就更加好了
然后呢,你们可以在这个位置里头,你就可以看到他是谁的品,谁家的店
然后呢,你看,哦,这个里头就是他的,那我就可以去扫码
然后呢,大家呢,可以呢,在这个位置里头呢,大家可以直接去扫码
然后你们就可以去看一下,看一下什么呢,看一下,他们家最近有没有上传一些新品,然后呢,他们家如果最近在上传一些新品,拿起新品销量都还可以,那这种新品就是你们机会,我不一定是选他们家的包款,明白我的意思吗,他既然做的这么好,你们可以看见,做的这么好,说明他们家不是一款,你们发现,他们家可能是好多产品,你们能明白我的意思吗,所以呢,这个是一种逻辑啊,就是大家呢,可以去选择去查看店铺当中的一些
新款
好,讲到这以后呢,第二个板块呢,我们就算是讲完了,第一个板块是基本的去判断,一个什么样的品好,基本的逻辑得知道,第二个维度是什么呢,知道这些好卖的品,到哪里去找,三个维度可以去找品,第一个是没有任何门槛的,第二个和第三个是要求你们店铺得上传这个行业的品,得去成交一单,你才能够看见,明白我的意思吗,那问题来了,那
我方向是有了,那用什么样的工具可以看他这个,这个品到底能不能跟,好不好跟,所以呢,来讲第三件事情,叫净品分析工具
那么,精品分析工具,哪些呢?第1个是免费的,第1个是哪呢?抖音的选品广场。然后呢,第2个是哪呢?蝉妈妈,要单独买的。第3个的话呢,罗盘,然后呢,上面有个市场。
市场里头呢,有一个竞争。分别来讲一下他们三个工具的优势和劣势。好了,来看第1个工具。第1个工具呢,还是大家来到整个抖音。但是如果说大家是在抖音里头直接去看他们家这个销量,没有任何意义。为什么呢?原因是因为他在这个位置里头,不管是卖了多少单,这是个累计销量。我不知道他是一个月卖的,还是多久卖的,明白我的意思吗?所以如果说你们想看一个品,嗯,一个月卖了多少呢?
到哪呢?到刚才选品的那个位置里头,大家可以去看,到哪呢?到我,我这个里头,大家看见没有?上面是不是有一个电商带货呀?有没有电商带货?然后呢,这个位置里头,他会有一个电商带货,电商带货里头,大家可以看见没有?这个里头,他会有一个,有个什么?看到没有?这里头有一个什么?对,这个位置里头的话,他会有一个选品广场,然后在这个选品里头,他会有一个选品广场。
在这个选品广场里头,大家比如说,你们看到这个品,看见没有?点进去以后,我看到的全部都是越销量,看见没有?越销量多少,而且呢,我点进去以后,我还可以看到,然后呢,我点进去以后,我还可以看到什么东西呢?可以看到没有?这个是趋势,你看见没有?能不能看到这个品,它是什么样的一个趋势啊?看到吗?30天,几号上的品?1月3号上的品,现在几号?
现在几号?7号,才4天时间,然后呢,你们可以看到,卖了多少单呢?卖了1.4万单,哪个渠道卖的呢?点直播,直播卖了2万单,然后呢,点视频,视频卖了10单,然后呢,点,好像说老师,那那个剩下的8000,那剩下的8000就是通过商品卡出的,对吧?可以看到没有?可以看趋势,而且呢,他还可以看90天的时间啊,
这个位置里头呢,不是说只能看30天,他还可以看到一个商品的90天的一个数据,而且可以看人群,但是唯一的点在哪呢?唯一不好的点就是他不是所有的款都能看到,他你想看到这个款前提就是你的同行,他有把这款商品加到精选联盟,如果说你的同行并没有把商品加入到精选联盟里头,你是看不到的,明白我的意思吗?所以呢,这个地方的品,
前提是什么?前提就是你的同行商品必须在,商品呢,已经加入了精选联盟,加入精选联盟以后,你可以去看,可以看哪些数据呢?可以看销量,可以看渠道,然后呢,可以看趋势,可以看人群,都有,而且还免费,第二个工具是什么呢?第二个工具的话呢,是禅妈妈,禅妈妈也可以看,
大家呢,可以直接到百度里头,到百度里头呢,大家可以直接的去搜索禅妈妈,然后在百度里头搜索完禅妈妈,以后,大家看见没有,这个位置里头,上面是不是有一个商品啊,然后呢,比如说,我现在想看棉拖鞋,那我在这里头呢,去搜,叫,棉拖鞋,
然后呢,大家呢,到这个位置里头,你们看见没有,白嫖的工具是可以的,就是点进去开始要花钱的,但是单纯在外面来,
看,你们可以看到没有,它的趋势能看到吗?然后呢,你们发现,他们家卖了一万单,你看看见,直播卖了多少单,商品卡卖了多少单,短视频卖多少单,每个渠道卖多少单,能看见吗?但是呢,你只要点进去,反正呢,就要钱,也就是说,点进去所有的数据呢,都是要花钱的,所以,第二个,馋妈妈,啥都好,唯一的,唯一的缺点就是要,对,她是要收费的,
加盖不便宜,但是呢,白票的功能是可以啊,可以看到什么东西呢,可以看销量,可以看趋势,可以看渠道,而且还可以看到她推广的一些素材,然后呢,都可以看,第三个位置大家去选品的时候,到哪里呢,到,罗盘,然后呢,上面有个市场,市场里头呢,它会有一个叫,竞争,看见没有,这里是不是有个叫,
竞争,也就是这个时候,教大家几个技能,哪几个技能呢,第一个,怎么把竞争对手加进去,大家看见没有,这里头它会有一个叫做,竞争对比,然后呢,你们呢,只要在这个位置里头,你们选择商品,那就选商品,但是,我在选择商品的时候,怎么把这个商品加进来呢,你看这里头是已经有的,那你得点击上面这个地方,上面说有个叫做,竞争管理啊,看见没有,你得把你竞争对手加进来,所以呢,这个功能是到哪里去看的,这个功能的话呢,
是到罗牌,上面呢,有个市场,市场里头呢,它会有个竞争对比,然后呢,你在这个位置里头呢,你可以添加竞争对手,你可以在这个位置头呢,来添加,所以它的位置是一,二,三,四,五,拍张照片,其实这个数据是所有页面里头数据最完整的,但是有一点,
什么一点呢,你们看不到别人的类目,你们只能看到是你们在卖什么类目的产品,你就能看什么类目,二,新开店铺看不了,它要求你们的店铺必须要有评分,有评分的店铺才能看,有评分的意思就是店铺最起码出了30单以上,一个月出了30单以上,你就可以看到这个类部的所有的数据了,明白我的意思吗,好,那第二件事情是怎么把竞争对手给加进来呢,比如说你看,
我在这里头,上面有个竞争管理,点击添加,然后呢,我可以添加我的竞争对手,上面是复制商品链接,怎么复制一个商品链接呢,大家可以直接去抖音。
然后呢,比如说我现在看到某一款商品。
比如说我现在呢,看这款商品,那我可以点击一下它,然后点击完以后,上面这个地方是不是有个分享,分享完以后,底下这里头是不是有个复制链接,看到吗?然后呢,你们复制一下链接,然后你们在这个位置里头呢,给它点击粘贴,然后呢,点击搜索,但是不可添加,为什么呢?
原因是我跟他的类幕和他的类幕,看见没有?不一样,但是这样的话,正常来讲,你就可以把它给加进来了,所以呢,第三个位置在哪里呢?第三个位置的话呢,在罗盘,上面有一个市场,下面有一个叫做竞争对比,上面呢,它会有一个商品,好,那么讲完这个东西以后呢,那第三个位置,
我知道用什么样的工具去看,而且呢,所有的数据最全面,最准确的,其实是它,但是就是说,这个工具想看啊,它有个前提,就是一,只能看你们的整个主营类目,哪个类目销量高就看哪个类目,知道呢?第二个,它必须是要有店铺有评分,它才能够看,店铺有评分,评分才能看,好,那我现在也知道用什么样的工具来分析
分析我的竞争对手了,那这是第三件事情,我要怎么判断我这个竞争对手,到底行还是不行,是这样的道理吧?所以呢,我来讲第三件事情,叫竞品分析,怎么判断我这个同行,行还是不行?所以呢,来讲第三个,叫竞品分析
好,但是呢,今天早上呢,嗯,讲不完了,我们今天早上呢,先讲到这
二,给大家呢,回顾一下,我们今天早上整个课程讲哪些内容啊,需要拍照的,可以先拍一下照片,就是我们的思路是很清晰的,找竞争对手,一,到哪可以找到我的竞争对手,二,用哪些工具可以分析我的竞争对手,三,竞争对手要怎么去分析它,好,那么今天早上的课程当中,给大家去讲了哪些内容呢,今天早上的课程当中呢,主要呢,是给大家去讲几大块内容,第一大块内容里头呢,其实是跟大家
去讲到整个行业该怎么去分析,行业分析里头讲了两个东西,一个是基础的行业分析,什么是基础行业呢,有没有市场,趋势怎么样,好不好卖,竞争怎么样,这个就是行业的基础,我分析,第二个维度的分析的话呢,叫进阶分析,进阶分析是分析这个行业在抖音里头好不好做,意思就是在抖音里头,大家是通过哪个渠端卖掉的货,第二个,大家卖了什么样的价格,我的同行前20名,他们有没有利润,什么价格带,好卖,所以呢,这个是分析抖音,意思就是
不能做的品,不能做的行业,尽快的去偷弃,尽快的去放弃它,所以呢,第一件事情,行业分析,第二件事情里头呢,是教大家选品,选品呢,有四种选品的方法,最建议的是商机中心,商机中心就是平台把好卖的品都已经告诉你们了,所以呢,我其实是在教大家,在这个页面里头,一,该怎么去选择,二,分析它的哪些数据,找完这个数据以后,绝对好的款,到哪里去找,
包括这个款,怎么样才能够发布起来以后,怎么样才能获得平台的扶持,讲了四件事,不是说找到这个款就有扶持,找到这个款,你得关联它,你才有扶持,明白我的意思吗,好了,那么,第二个板块的话呢,是教大家去跟款,大家跟款没有讲完,只讲两个东西,一个到哪找到这些款,一个是怎么用什么样的工具,可以看这些款的数据,好,那下午来讲什么呢,
下午的话呢,两件事,第一件事情呢,选品还有,选品还有两种方法,选品没有讲完,对吧,包括怎么分析竞争对手这个东西呢,我也还没有讲完,那么第二件事情是干嘛呢,当选品讲完以后,光选品行不行,告诉你们一个很残酷的现实,同样的一款商品,好卖的品,平台就给五家流量,也就是说的更加直白一点,如果说你是第六家,你的流量就会比较少,前五,
五家是有比较大的流量的,那就是谁先冲上去,谁就有流量,谁先冲上去,谁就有生意,对吧?那问题来了,那我怎么样才能够冲上去,所以呢,我们下午进入到第二个环节,来讲讲小店的流量到底在哪里,我们到底应该做一些什么样的事情,我才能够获得这些流量,好,那我们上午呢,先讲到这块,你们先别走,就要
早上有没有人来找你们签名字,没有,稍微等一下,你们需要签一下名字,纸给我几张,签名的纸,给我4张,白纸吧,4张
大家那个名字签一下,你们横排往后去,你们的名字签一下,名字签一下,对,下午还在这个教室啊,然后呢,嗯,下午呢,一般大家都会比较瞌睡,吃完饭以后大家可以来休息一会儿,然后容易瞌睡的呢,可乐呀,咖啡呀,
喝一点,因为呢,其实你们会发现运营课和基础课不一样,基础课的内容呢,它是比较散碎的,它更多的是强调让大家动手去做,到了运营课,其实你们会发现,一个早上有大量的知识是大家需要去吸收的,所以呢,我希望啊,大家呢,稍微的休息一下,因为留给大家做的时间不多。
没关系,对着,关联相片，关联相片，关联相片，对,但是我有点事情,你指的是什么,就是找到这个款以后,怎么去关联它,是吗,有流量扶持的话呢,是这样子的,就是你到后台的这个位置里头,比如说就这个品牌,你要点进去,点进去以后,底下,要么你就直接在这里头发布了相似的,要么你已经发布完以后,你在这里头点击关联,然后呢,把它跟店铺当中的品牌,
去匹配上,点进去以后底下的位置。对,最下面那个地方。